l'analyse avec va nous a mis un petit
peu en retard même si ça j'appelle pas
ça du retard le match va durer trois
heures et demie si on n'a toujours pas
joué on n'a
pas le temps donc on va se mettre à
suivre maxime dont contre fabien dont
maxime qu'il ya un grand favori comme je
le disais un petit peu en avant-match
fabiano qui est pas forcément à un
expert du blitz et rapide ouais puis au
delà de sa fab
bas ils ont fait un commentaire changes
alimentent fin nous qui commentent ont
beaucoup ouais
ça te crève et mais bon maxime est en
vacances donc of
votre c - crûment des vacances en oui
mais bon après il est à 1 pour maxime
filippa retrait dubaï c'est quoi ce jeu
à 22h oui match va avancer machin tu
sais pas bon
kelly collection d'hôtels si c'est vrai
la connexion peut jouer voilà il ya
quelques facteurs les amis moi je vais
je vais préparer les caméras non mais
c'est vrai je suis vraiment content de
ce nom ce travail est ce que tu apprends
enfin ça apprend des trucs tellement
important en fait des gens sans fin les
gens se rendent pas compte j'espère
qu'ils se rendent compte
mais ouais mais bon on a eu une info
très rarement de
de maxime qui a une bonne connexion
via une connexion qui cliquent
après
après c'est toujours pareil les
connexions d'hôtels best où l'on rentre
vers 20h machin qui rêve du petit
netflix ou je sais pas quoi
jay amazon prime ou je ne sais quoi mais
d'un coup
d'un coup c'est complet c'est complexe
attends je demandé
le lien pour les gammes ouais ouais je
veux le lien pour les cavs en fait
c'était soit on avait les caps dès la
première minute on faisait pas le nostra
vladut ceinture et c'était à mon tour et
dès 9h 3 ne suis pas parti suivons les
calmes j'ai envie de te dire
rester webcam devant un ordi enfin
c'est pas l'attention d'un match de
championnat du monde c'est tout ce que
je veux dire par là donc si nous les
aimants que pour deux trois parties il
n'y a pas mort d'homme quoi
mais d'habitude y met il me met un lien
vous les automatiquement bon bein non
pas me croire détrompe toi
en fait il suffit que tant des besoins
une fois et tapas le lien quoi
c'est un peu toujours pareil c'est la
fois où tu en a le plus besoin était le
plus en retard que tu l'as pas quoi à
quelle heure ça commence on va ça
devrait avoir commencé déjà
mais ne vous inquiétez pas de toute
façon qu'on elecam ou pas les parties on
sait où elles partent donc ça il ya
aucun problème
elecam on devrait avoir bientôt
quelqu'un qui me qui m'écrit 5e c'est
pas évident en lorgnant
ah ok c'est peut-être là
peut-être
gsk le régisseur en redif youtube ainsi
à
salvan si luigi galles temps de le clip
est enfin pas de clip et mais de la
fin de la mède propre en fait de prendre
le truc est de couper le début d'une
demi-heure à me faire pour que pour
qu'on puisse mettre en ligne demain
matin si ludique a le temps de le faire
je vais lui écrire si l'epa sur le live
on peut le mettre en redif m'a même si
c'est les mêmes parties ce qui est
intéressant je trouve ouest aux portes
une petite vision sympathique
je crois que ça joue ouais ça joue alors
à temps donc je suis sur le truc
ok
du coup l'équipe
attend je ne comprends pas pourquoi elle
s'affichera automatiquement déjà on à la
partie c'est maxime donc avec les blancs
pour les calmes attend donc de toujours
pas et les speech est ce pour ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas suivi sa
nouvelle saison là mais c'est en 3 trois
cas dans ce coin il ya du 5 minutes et
du 3 minutes et d'une minute à la fin la
suisse 5 minutes trois ans plus une
seconde ou deux ou trois où je peux
quand même parcours donc ça va être
assez lent en fait
voilà ça va durer trois heures trois
amis c'est pas trop
et donc première partie maximale et
blanc une espagnole et c'est pas la
ligne
[Musique]
principale un caruana qui joue pas s'en
apercevoir deux
habituels et qui joue une vente steinitz
différé donc avec des six voies la
maxime que j'ai un petit fou g5 provoqué
f6 un peu enfermé le fou du film qui est
aux anges et 7 il est reparti une fois
qu'ils étaient attaqués et qui renâcle
et le peu qu'il y en a 6 bat soit pour
revenir en g4 embêter le fou 3 soit des
fois à venir à f 7 colmater la diagonale
et à maxime de jouer donc il peut faire
h3 il peut probablement je joue un coup
de tours au vin ou cavaliers à 3 ou
foulée 3 où je donne plein d'options
petits trucs importants ce qui concerne
fable et les prépas les joueurs jouent
pas dans ce genre de tournoi leur prépa
principal non après d'autres sites en
finale tu peux te dire tiens allez je
suis un petit effort sera quand même pas
une prépa de ouf mais pour mme zewde on
sait qu'il est chaude quand on me prend
au sérieux je venais des trucs
intéressants alors voilà il avait pas de
connexion cette année oui mon et l hôtel
en slovénie
on a vu mieux quoi pour internet ouais
enfin c'est en train d'arriver à l'ecam
je les ai trouvés sur notre joie du
public ouais je clique désolé si tu me
vois je trouve cliquer raison donc le
max qui a d'abord échangé en en 5 qui a
ramené le fond en b3 pour empêcher rock
et un coup qu'on pourrait imaginer c'est
peut-être cavaliers à 5 mais peut-être
que maxime ont envie de faire un petit
coup de fouet des cinq au passage
bon ok c'est 6 mai en même temps après
des fois je sais pas quoi jean le cam et
à singapour il est plus ou moins fermés
tu reviens et je me sens disait on va
voir ce à quoi la géologie in food et
5,6 n'ont
alors pas mal apposition des blancs
comme la visuellement tu as besoin de
joueurs d'arriver dessus puisque au
lendemain de deux charbonné
fabien dans un club d'échecs quoi je
sais pas actuellement il est cher
hentsch pour pour le commentaire du
championnat du monde ac vont devoir
litres soit votre porte ou doigt par
tout ça les deux
cartons dans la tête parce que pour vos
familles mieux et parce que tu es ben
s'assure prix maximum ce qui a valu à 5
je suis pas sûr vous en fait a priori
c'est le coup tenté de jouer pour
dégager le fruit pour un rock est donc
métrologie peut-être que je comprends
rien c'est pas le problème mais je
trouve ça logique
alors ce qui fait un restaurant food
estime qu un fou c'est dos et un fois
mais en fait bref dessin je me dis bah
c'est 6 qui si il vient se fout de
vous j'ai cinq ans qui attaquent la dame
qui appartient un peu voilà bon c'est 8
il faut des cinq maintenant alors sur
ses 6 6 le faire peut-être partir juste
en b3 tu échanges et affaiblit un peu
des fils alors juste pour tenir un
maxime qui envoie une info qui envoie
une info à 19 heures pile voilà il a dit
ils ont créé des pauses en milieu de
segments donc ya des pauses
supplémentaires ces plaisirs et voile
est trés heureux vie est très très
heureux donc il y aura des pauses à 45
minutes petite pause de cinq minutes
supplémentaires minimum minimum
permettra de bien souffler pour pour les
joueurs
mais c'est une information qui vient de
maxime abba
de première main maxime très heureux
ça fait plaisir
faby qui peut aller bouffer souffou
hockey
l'info maxime donc des pauses fap qui
nous permettront de mettre de la pub ah
bah oui là aussi il faut mettre beaucoup
aller toujours le ratio
je vous rassure aide quoi en fait
pendant toutes les poses julie plus je
pige au public c'est magnifique
c'était juste pour ça que l'on fait des
pauses en photo alors lover les décalés
voyez un truc qu'il ya un truc qui me
chiffonne sur le corner mais je ne sais
pas pourquoi le fond du jaune bleu roi
et un truc qui est décalée mais j'arrive
pas à 3 savoir quoi
c'est pas de ta faute non non vous
et on verra quand les scores ce qu'on a
ce qu'on sera affichée sera plus facile
de juger
ok donc celui qui des deux baies 5 mes5
pourquoi pas
magnifique à cuatro
très bien ça pousse un
silence ça pousse une émission sur
françois kahn silence ça pousse d'un
truc jardinage et
rock mais ça va en fait pour les noirs
tout ennui sa maman mais tel n'est pas
si nul 1-1 avant de peindre c'est une
sale tronche mais ça va
on maxime qui a réfléchi pour le mans
après il a le temps tu as le temps de
rentrer dans ton match quand même il y
aura beaucoup de parties
oui
donc il y aura là il ya le temps de
de se mettre en place après fabiano il
faudra pas de laisser trop rentrer dans
le match que je pense que maxime peut
lui mettre la tête sous l'eau et après
le manger en requins en fait je dirais
plus le match à lens - c'est pourquoi
bien de quoi
un plus ça je pense va bien on va se
faire marcher dessus trois plus un
salaire des plus tôt maxime et 5 + 1 un
peu maxime mais pas de beaucoup quoi
on veut il ya beaucoup de maxime de
vancouver que plus a pu les cadences se
réduisent plus maxime et devant après
comme on le disait il ya le côté aussi
décalage horaire 1h du mat mais bon
maxime ça lui fait pas peur non dont
l'un 1h du mat c'est normal c'est moi
qui dis donc une forme lors du vrai bah
oui après il ya la haine billet il ya un
peu de tout voir y est bien
c'est que la logique grutier les noms je
sais pas les amis la logique qui a mes
moyens il ya un jour de décalage un
endroit je sais pas pourquoi après ça
empêche pas de regarder les parties
graphiques je comprends pas comment
incarnation pour l autre son club en
fait tu peux les censier n'importe qui
sur un club par pays dont carla il sera
probablement jamais une partie pour ton
club ami lamela heroes hamas aussi passé
le club de kazim qui était son
entraîneur pour longtemps peut-être
toujours je crois pas
donc j'ai vu que kazim travail canadien
leur gaz
il s'est mis à faire de bons résultats
et rien ici glazart
maxime qui va me prendre de l'espace
allèles dampha ben ouais ça pousse ça
pousse mais bon après ce que notre
contrée voilà
faria c'est toujours pareil quand tu
prends de l'espace tu peux laisser des
plumes
en tout cas ils cliquent fabiano en ce
début de match il joue plus vite que
maxime ce qui peut être
surprenant mais bon c'est que la
première partie on le répète là le fou
pourrait peut-être se décaler nom est
mal placée sous un banc les estoniennes
surtout pas bizarre ce qu'il faut à chis
paraît simple à celle d'un saint pacôme
coup pour se décaler mais non c'est un
peu alice milla clic et
hop ça clique du coup parte les pillages
3 le quidam d un
sahara clic ça va cliquer après maxime
c'est un peu un diesel non ces matches
il lui faut une deux parties pour
rentrer dedans un peu comme magnus ouais
c'est
pas évident parce que tu sais que ça va
être très long donc ton effort j'ai
envie de te dire tu me la mets tout
appris et pas trop suffisamment de
puissance
oui mais là j'aime pas ça peut sur
maxime
parce que
[Musique]
la juste voie de faire un peu attaqué et
droit il ya la paire de fou en face
facile pour quelle heure tu as qu'une
faiblesse cédé 6 mais comment tu
l'attaquent donc sa peine faiblesse et
donc que tu peux monter ta position rage
et sade les tours avancé g5 g4 tiens un
truc dont on va parler c'est que le move
est fou comme il ya plus d espace pour
les noirs il est pas si mauvais ah oui
pauvre du toit il est même plutôt bon et
là plus de cases
mais carey la faim qui avaient trois
bien joué en quelques chiffres ce qu ils
vont venir mais
on voyait
la tacc comme sa famille peut-être dam
des deux
parce que tu attaques un peu des 6 un
peu g5 donc d'un message imaginer hk
peut-être
sa clique
et menace le pion une dame j'ai c'est
que peut-être du g37 les cinq fois f4
non ouais
bon pas simple je n'ai
peut-être pas simple pas simple à jouer
avec les noirs non plus pas plus simple
à jouer mais c'est toi tu peux cliquer
avec les 90 enfin
et g3 et va te mettre qui rêvent 5
je suis pas convaincue du clic de fabien
2 1 et il n'a pas le temps de calculer
le joueur américain et ça devient
beaucoup plus complexe
pourquoi tu joues
je pense qu'il ya plus cela les change
avec le souci de créer très peu et
gagnant 1,4 sache qui est ce que c'était
mal joué de la part de fabiano terrible
mais je pense que ça va être le scénario
de beaucoup de partis quand il ya peu de
temps à la pendule fabi il n'arrive pas
en fait c'est ça le fasse on veut
apprendre à cliquer
oui j'ai pas qu'à cliquer sans réfléchir
et cliquez à tout prendre et sandales et
coiffe un véhicule patron en fait je
veux ton franchise fou j'ai 5 mai
kg 4 franchement tu vois je crois il
veut pas un an et photos en 3d à oui oh
il a cliqué fabi a mais fou 3 yves leroy
h
peut-être qu'il n'a pas vu vous n'avez
pas vu du tout façon obligé de leur
[ __ ] mais notre entourage c'est
peut-être bon la tap adam prend comme il
fallait un projet 2 maxime avait pas vu
non plus sa clique qui te donne un tour
h7 seul coup ça clique au hasard ces
gosses devant clic à la sa clique leur
attaque de feu dit oui votre c'est pas
très dur mais c'est dangereux pour max
non parce qu'il ya du matin que dans des
raisons jouer après toujours faire des
matchs 5
fait changer tout raté huit matchs quand
même f 6 3 6 3 et 5 non magnifique
oui gère ces jolis ouvrages 6,3 g saint
gall entourage
la finale ah oui ma tante et du vin
c'est encore la petite maëlle et du
retour à troyes ce qu'est ce qui vous
prend ces trois noms d'elie me voyez pas
bien mais elle était trop encore ouf
je pense que gross c'est vrai ça c'est
sûr
regard regarde ça contre regarde sa
clique côté maxime
peut-être le réseau tennant ou la 3g 3
c'est bien joué
b45 dois-je puntos à les deux fronts
rows 4 des cas bien joué c'est trois
fois qu'il réussisse à les bloquer sur
blanc ses proches ouais je suis pas sur
mais bon dos au chp une touche quand
même
prénom c'est bien joué là pour maxime
vont arriver
attends attends attends ils tant il peut
encore le faire maxime
non un habitué de vedici récupération
s'est apprécié bouffe tous les pions oui
ouais bon première défaite mais le match
est encore loin il reste il reste encore
trois heures de trois heures et demie de
match fab ça va plus les pose juste la
puce est ok bon c'est quoi ce 3h20 plus
les pose donc ça à maxime a encore le
temps de revenir ce n'est que la
première partie environ il ya 22 23
parties ça va un début de match un petit
peu compliqué une défaite dommage parce
que femme je crois que ça allait bien
puis mal pire bien pire au mal
et puis fini et ça s'est joué au clic se
joue au clic donc on a vu qu au clic qui
est bon là l'ouverture se passe déjà
bien le cadrer les variances hessing
cours en détresse on n'est pas inquiet
en ce début de match fabre on est quand
même confiant fabiano va montrer son
vrai niveau ambiance
on verra bien c'est pas très grave mais
très importants comme match pardon
pardon bah oui mais je vais te mettre au
diapason d'accord à toi tu étais sur le
match de championnat du monde de base
beaucoup toi tu disais ah tiens carlson
dépôts va changer spica est par contre
vannes on y regarde pas du tout les
premières la première édition oui un
petit peu plus là non ça n'intéresse
plus tout bas c'est un peu toujours
l'histoire sur le même qui gagne à la
fin
le même format même
temps il faut justement donnait très
importante du coût encore chaque année
donnée
ouais non tout ça pour dire quoi dans
cette position pour en revenir sur
l'ouverture c'est caruana il a joué une
anti grünfeld il a promulgué en c3 il a
fait kf3 et maxime il a joué une
position de benoni qui fait souvent sur
start de coûts est juste une très bonne
position il est arrivé à échanger une
pièce légère donc il un peu plus d
espace pour naviguer qui essaient 5 très
actif qui peut aller cliquer en d3 ou en
b3 petite pression sur 4 donc moi je met
les nerfs
oui c'est sympa comme position 1 fabiano
qui va pas jouer ces grosses prépa sur
la grüne fans de maxime non évidemment
donc quand on parlait aussi du duo 1
contre 1 du match up entre guillemets du
head's up même comme disent les
américains dans ce format là il ya un
autre avantage que maximale a en
l'occurrence sur fabiano c'est que
fabien de son point fort c'est les
ouvertures les prépas et dans un tournoi
de moindre importance très important
bien sûr ah tu croit aimer dans un
tournoi de moindre importance fabiano ne
va utiliser aucune préparation théorique
mais on va justement c'est intéressant
parce que c'est mauvaise cadence pour
fabiano
prépa des prépa donc il a quand même
deux points négatifs on va voir s'ils
s'en sort mais c'est sûr que si tu
arrives et ses deux plus grandes forces
surtout entre guillemets la grünfeld
serait point faible de maxime en fait tu
enlèves le point faible de maxime et
enlève le point fort de fabiano prince
est quand même complexe mais bon après
c'est du lied sa clique c'est si le clic
au hasard qui va qui va faire la
différence enfin ce soit c'est très très
mal pour fabien 7 / - food maire de
l'option des 5
maxime grand grand favori un de ce match
mais après fabien non moi je les ai vus
parfois je sais pas pourquoi sur un
écrit blitz bien certains joueurs c'est
rare ouais bon
petit joueur quoi il peut faire quoi oui
mais j'ai en fait tu t'y attends le
général n'a pas trop te dis bon il va
perdre mais c'est en fait tout d'un coup
il ya un jour de temps en temps ben tu
sais pas pourquoi ça clique et quand ç'a
cliqué qu'il allait coûts qui viennent
ça reste pas bien haut caruana quoi donc
joueur italien
quand sa clique ont même pris la
popularité en fait je pouvais pas il
avait la dame attaque
voilà on voit ses pions plus pour maxime
regarder juste ce qu'avait laissé cinq
magnifiques et le fouet f1 qui sert à
rien un plot en plus on pourra lui
rendre le pion ce recueil perdu dans un
terreau postaux un pion quelques
postures ça c'est de ne quasiment vides
abandonnées comme c'est fini face aux
écrasements
ça va faire un partout la réalisation
express de maxime et on voit un petit
peu dans cette partie pourquoi on pense
que le joueur français est large favori
de ce match
après il faut que la connexion tienne il
ya aussi le feuilleton
soit ça t'amuse mais
il ya quand même deux joueurs déjà sur
les 7 premiers ya deux des sept premiers
matches qui se sont joués à la connexion
quand même avec peu plus cliqués il fait
pas quitté le gers est quand même
beaucoup
qui rassure
et 25% des matches qui se jouent à la
cua
et ça c'est
non il est pas du match juste à dubai il
a du mal
je fais plaisir mais la raison enfin
pourquoi pas à faire des petites
vacances
profitez aussi de suivre le match
championnat du monde sur place je crois
qu'ils en iso très bonne chichaoua oui
d'ailleurs à tout moment qui peut
arriver dans la chambre derrière avec la
chicha à la pollution est vraiment
catastrophique 1 pour les blancs cède
1.14 au prochain et au japon tout comme
tomtom vient enfin je sais pas pourquoi
ça va ça vient de maximy d'attendre
tranquillement laissé filer le temps ah
oui ça ne tient pas ce que j'attends le
parti où je suis plus fort il fait pas
d'âme 24 bon après va faire il va le
faire à tout moment with the cette
plante inquiets le
400e de se chauffer je sentis sourire de
marloux admet son visage ni vers la sq
ouais
si chaque équipe à moi et bien sûr
fabien uc pas non plus lui même pourquoi
il joue cette partie là
nos frenchies je te mets là tu joues tu
pense qu'il va être gérée en fait ouais
locaux de tchekhov ou je sais pas
mais de trésors
non mais max et pains préparatoire de
carlson un bon truc comme un petit choc
détrompe toi
voilà
bien son jeu est-ce que ça compte pour
les lots ce genre de partir non pas du
tout déjà à l'essai c'est une cadence
bits donc c'est pas c'est pas les
cadences sur le lot principal est là en
plus on est sur un tournoi sur internet
donc qui n'est pas homologué par la fidh
on est on est on est sur un mal qui
exhibition on est ce serait l'équivalent
pas du navire cup mais un match
d'exhibition qui au tennis parfois
match aux africains
eux-mêmes l'opa hoffmann cap - ça compte
un peu non ouais alors qu'au début non
ça comptait un petit peu mais
non même la coupe davis ça compte ou non
la coupe davis à contre une sorte de
débarquer si vous voulez voilà
plus ou moins alors que avec déclics
ah oui l'argent à gagner ah oui un petit
peu comme n'est pas énorme d'ailleurs ce
tournoi tu peux qua non mais c'est pas
c'est pas mirobolant je suis peut-être
quelqu'un à l'alva le premier prix mais
c'est pas ça c'est du 30 40 minutes je
crois quelque chose dans ce style là
c'est pas des 200 mini look noir elles
vont sur internet c'est pas du deux sans
trois cent mille ans mais c'est cool x
1,3 à 30 milles pour jouer quatre
matches sur internet c'est cool mais je
ne sais pas non plus
puis tout se vaut bien mes
genoux ces camionnettes imite le premier
prix non je pense pas que ce soit 10000
ans depuis
2000 au vainqueur de chaque 8e et un don
de près donc là il ya un petit ya un
petit 3 me la prendre sur ce match et
c'est peut-être j'ai pas une bêtise mais
c'est peut-être 5000 pour les quarts
8000 pour la demie et 15000 de plus pour
la finale ça monte un peu crescendo
chaque match au final ça tu vois c'est
un petit 40000 quoi bon match réalisé je
vais apprendre à regarder c'est vrai que
c'est plus les américains qui sont
intéressés par les prize pool ouais ben
loulou c'est un peu mon agent s'en fout
en fait mais ça s'est même tabou on fait
notoire ou
non en fait je juste pas du tout ce que
c'est le pressent pour venir
c'est pas facile parce qu'il met l'autre
price vous complet et le prize pool il
est divisé en match et c'est pas facile
d'avoir une lecture
bon une petite
anglaise ont été pensés par trois ans je
passe sous le ventre 3 ou si la miss
clic en tout cas ça se passe bien
l e3 pas voulu de maximy attire une
transgenre mains celles émises click
wheel une belle position tout ce qui
rejoint bomber peut-être que j'ai déjà
battu pourquoi me prendre l'espagnol
alors que 2/3 tellement plus fort qu
1,3 après ça s'est joué même en candide
candidats carey qui n'avait joué 3 il ya
un quart yakine à nos mains de khanaqine
qui a commencé par je vois très bien la
partie en question mais je sais pas si
elle vous pourrez 3 ou c4 je crois que
ça commence par je suis cagnina commence
par trois ces paquets f3 des 5,80 non je
crois que c'est vraiment et trois
premiers le droit au premier comme se
trouvera quand même des options
je pense que ces deux trois premiers
mais bon je suis pas sûr prix totaux
partout retrait mais 32000 pour les 18
pour les huitièmes machin et tout grande
finale 20000 total cent mille ouais
c'est pas énorme
total cent mille dollars tu vois je
trouve pas que ça mirobolants on voit se
souvient mais c'est un oui il ya plus
ça va être un massacre ouais ça va de
plus en plus sans répartie et bizarre
mais c'est qu'elle prend 1,4 au prochain
c'est ce noir
j'ai regardé la dame quoi comme ça bouge
pas c'est fixé c'est terrible
j'ai fait un petit tour b1 pour pour
décrypter ces trois défendre le four b2
prendre quatre autres un pion et puis
puisse être une victoire encore après
très fort aux trois mois après je dois
dire que par expérience de commenter les
parties c'est ce qu'il ya de pire
honnêtement pour jouer le contre temps
de commenter tu commandes des tournois
c'est ce qui défonce le plus de cerveau
pour jouer après
ces genres c'est mieux de blitz et six
heures par jour comme un idiot et de
revenir le sixième jour beats et que de
commenter quatre heures par jour ou 2
rien faire parce qu'en fait quand tu
commentes tu tu ne bosses tourne et une
baisse son rythme déjà mais pour
expliquer et en plus tu dois vérifier
tout alors dit parce que t'as pas le
temps de calculer quand tu commentes
donc tu vas faire deux choses terribles
pour jouer aux échecs c'est te mettre à
la vitesse des gens mais depuis que dire
et de plus calculer et est généralement
en sortie de commentaires j'ai besoin de
deux jours où tu vois je vois plus
j'arrive plus à bouger les pièces en
fait ça à l'électrique ne viennent plus
tu as dû expliquer trop de mauvais coups
tu as du talent eu trop de polluer
l'esprit et je dois dire que moi c'est
un facteur que je pense est terrible
pour fabiano la plus il a pas l'habitude
de commenter je pensais pas je pense
encore et je suis même certain certain
maintenant en vue des premières parties
que ça ça va être
une difficulté supplémentaire en tout
cas au début puis ça peut
prendre que m
prendre 2 à 5 finalement mon les pièces
pourri s'ouvre un peu parce que sur la
cinq de base sur le faible et s'incline
mais après un petit cbcb c'est peut-être
la colonne c'est bon après je veux dire
c'est qu'une fois qu'on a la sale qui
est minutes c'est simple homonyme tête
tu peux faire un peu comme spatiale
barre toi tu donnes tu reviens bouffe
est ce que à ce niveau là le niveau le
l'enjeu financier augmente la pression
est donc plus d'erreurs alors non enfin
pour pour ces joueurs là en fait un
trente quarante mille dollars de premier
prix c'est pas une somme importante en
réalité par rapport aux prix qu'ils ont
l'habitude de d'engranger dans les
tournois pu et les sponsors les
sponsorship et c est ça se remarque
d'ailleurs énormément avec le match
n'est pas car je cède en ce moment fan
de transition en fait ils sont pas
stressés comme la dynepo le 1 million de
de la première place bon c'est pas ça
c'est pas très important c'est pas ça
qui les skis qui leur met la pression
mais c'est plus le titre de champion du
monde à ce niveau là c'est plus l'enjeu
sportif qui met la pression que l'enjeu
est financier en tout cas pour des
joueurs de premier plan comme maxime
comme fabiano comme dépôt comme carl
scènes sont des joueurs qui gagnent déjà
très bien leur vie et j'ai envie de dire
cent mille euros de plus ou moins ça qui
va changer l'ordre où ils prennent
tout me prendre comme est
effectivement ont vu leurs gains
habituel pas de quoi leur mettre une
grosse pression après deux points des
joueurs de moindre envergure mondiale ah
bah oui je serai là je suivrai quoi
trente mille euros j'arrive plus à jouer
tu veux pas dit les peut-être fait une
assurance ouais ça alors que
je peux plus mature on pay bas du dos
est déjà plein qu'est ce que je fais
je pense que le petit million mais quand
même un peu la pression mais je n'ai pas
un million 0 en fait c'est un million 2
ou 1 800 mille fait déjà donc même si tu
perds tout à 800000 coppens s'appelait
bien quoi donc c'est juste 400 me de la
différence et
et plus rester dans l'histoire donc il
se trouve que j'ai faim l'âge j'ai
écouté les joueurs ne s'est pas une
affabulation et ouais
maxime est très très bien il ya le pion
dessinée manificat le four b2 la dame la
dame g4
très mal placé qui pourrait se faire
enfermer même en imaginer fouet deux
dames aussi cf cinq noms un truc comme
ça plus de cases devrait
aussi être long pour faire vite je crois
ces matches là
une petite éclaircie lors de la première
les fuit depuis
dur
c'est pas pour une ligne sur wikipédia
pour rentrer dans le hall of fame ah bah
oui dans le match de championnat du
monde un titre de champion du monde
c'est une valeur inestimable un peu le
récit rocard de master à la
seconde plus une pièce doit faire
d'alger 6 7 5 dans un match si tu
bouffes exercice et en heure je pensais
je vais essayer de récupérer mais je
crois que la même pas vu en fait qu'ils
ont tu joues tempo sur food
maxime qui rigole fally qui rien vu
c'est terrible
est-ce que dale moss is f 5 l enfermer
les dames h4
bon je sais pas je vais jusqu'à f5
pour 25 dans une pièce
et à peut-être trois intermédiaires
bon chance de jouer qui n'était pas vue
du tour
ça bon de me prendre pour comprendre
mais autour de dégager mon cette junte
ont de plus mais beaucoup de gens
préfèrent une pièce de
jusqu'à 4 de favi il appuie peut
s'organiser pour la voir en même temps
mais je pense que ça déconcentre plus
qu'autre chose à vrai dire se sert pas à
grand chose mais
gare aux participants oui oui enfin je
crois
et d'ailleurs c'est le favori du tour
avec l'éventuel gain du temps maxime
peut s'acheter chaise gaming
bas il n'est pas chez lui un les amis
froid qu'il ait choisi hemingway
mais là oui là il à dubaï en à l'hôtel
il participa le hb il gagne sa vie que
le h6 gagne très très très souvent ces
tournois c'est le grand favori cette
année encore même si wesley so peut être
dangereux il n'a pas très bien joué le
premier match abscon quest et commence
un peu à se désintéresser des toits
internet pour revenir en forme sur sur
le vent réel j'ai cette impression et
il va faire peut-être h4 maximy sinon
pour juste du ce match et où d'échangé
tout aussi ce qu'ils ont fait de la
seule tour active de la voiture en
portant dans son style
ils essayent de colmater un peu les
cases familles
sains qui joue sur les clous âge bon je
trouve que fabien vrai dire il a pas mal
défendue par rapport à la poubelle qu'il
avait avalé résiste 10 ou lille à 15
secondes
colocation on a besoin de moins il ya
une cour qui va débarquer sur
le pion qui va tomber
donc là ça intéressant sur l'île et il
veut te reprends cavaliers prend tour eu
un cas il prend des six ouais au moins
un beauf espions sur la route les
défendre mais bon
après il peut faire la déco aux siens
je crois pas que rennes déco vous a dit
maxime une bonne connexion à votre
collection que oui il faut cliquer à
tout moment tu voulais dire
tu peux quand même jouer des corps sains
at espères tu peux toujours jouer déco
c'est toujours intéressant
à sept jours un petit espoir
c'est le freeroll quoi mais il a
vraiment défendu en fait fabien de bons
maxime reste très bien il est un pion
plus c'est la position excellente mais
la position des noirs s'est pas écroulé
il veut un truc genre pions prend fou
bessette ils échangent les fous après il
tape un peu sur des six attourath elle
sera active era quart d'heure maxime il
va coleman et puis peut-être qu'à lyon
ce matin
mais ils cliquent fabi
en fait c'est pour ça que j'ai fabi un
certain moment j'attends que sur un
mauvais blisters dans ce position là
justement ils ces groupes notamment mais
en fait ils s'accrochent et tu as il y
joua
pratique j'ai quand même l'impression
que c'est un peu miraculeux être arrivé
là meriva la période
[Musique]
non mais il va la perdre mais
c'est pas aussi faible enfin certaines
fois il a des éclairs quoi
cinq élèves trois rois des trois mondes
sont rois un peu comme contre comme ali
reza éjecté à trop faire trop trop
impliquée des quatre échecs je suis
étonné qu'il n'ait jamais joué assez
bien joué ça file la cale pour les punto
punto
mais là il va être bien maxime ça
devrait faire le clown tôt
fait retour à cette fonte grise bye bye
sbaâ
en vrille la clique 1
qui ici cissé ou encore cliquant en 17
mai maxime reste avec une pièce de plus
de 500 projets si c'est trop ciao ciao
bello
ça fait ça fait 2-1 essart clic
ses
4,1 me michaud barbe ça elle seule chose
donc une petite anglaise
symétrique ainsi à faire aussi souvent
il fait pas suivre jusqu'au bout
non il joua il joue tranquille où
maxime qui joue tranquille au il faut
qu'il installe son jeu qui commence à
prendre le score et qui désespère en
fait fabiano pour le vrai pour le tuer
psychologiquement et il y aura vraiment
plus de matches
je pense dans ce genre de compétition et
de match août est favori c'est vraiment
important sur réussi à faire l'écart en
début de match tout seul pôle espoir
qu'on aimerait le match de coupe de
france tu te trouves pas mené au score
de 2 0 après 10 minutes et puis c'est
fini maïs et finirait par contre c'est à
la 70e minute qu'il ya un
après ça dit un peu de la roulette quoi
encore d'ailleurs les mecs montes tu
sais pas quoi dire contre est vrai que
ce match à l'avantagé d'être vraiment
très long on n'est bien sûr pas sûr que
ça tout à fait selon mais bon
on essaie être bien sûr
probablement deux trois fois plus de
temps sur quatre cinq six jours de trois
schémas 20 communes temps tu penses fois
pour être vraiment sur
moi j'y vois même pas ses matches
pourra jamais être vraiment sûr
voilà maxime de nouveau et par un jeu
pas trop ce qu'il a foutu failli le sens
que tu va décaler la dame en décèdent
faire flasher 3 et le pion à 6 ça va
plutôt devenir un point faible qu'un
point fort à
baader s'est joué par maxime aux besoins
de cette c'est logique quand on est vite
à vis du g2 les programmes externes
mais si c'est bien joué un maxime qui
défonce et 5 qui défend à
bahia patronne très grande diagonale la
tour veut partir on s'évite l'eau 38
comme ça tu vas voir je crains et
audemars à auxi aussi éventuellement les
couleurs inversées
à cinq exceptions h6 des gens c'est sûr
questionnable soit c'est une force parce
que c'est une épine dans le pied puis un
démâtage en maîtres du couloir genre des
matons g7 genre d'écueil angers 5 dans
des finales qui te font chier sur la
chaussette mais si tu le perds battue a
juste perdu trois temps pour les meneurs
pour te faire bouffer quoi alors j'en
profite pour dire qu'il y aura une
grosse compétition de rapides ebit à la
fin de l'année du 25 au 30 décembre je
suis très heureux d'air que c'est que ce
que ce que ce championnat du monde de
billes de ces rapts et lieux ait lieu il
a été confirmée donc il aura lieu du 25
décembre
du 25 au 30 décembre je sais pas si le
25 décembre c'est le jour de la première
partie jouée près de l'avion ou si ses
jours il prend l'avion parce que c'est
papa pas évident d'avoir une lecture sur
ces trouvera pas certain mais c'est vrai
en plus central +26 quand même on va
faire un petit conférence de presse et
peut-être a joué 27 28 29 euros pad
le gala 30 conférence de presse finale
et avions 31 quoi je pense que ça ajoute
26-27-28 rapide et le 29 et le 30 le miz
mais j'en suis pas sûr c'est peut-être
25 26 27 28 repos et 29 30 bon peu
importe c'est du 25 au 30 ce sera le
championnat du monde de rapides sur
trois jours puis le championnat du monde
de blitz sur deux jours et et c'est
vraiment une belle compétition et
j'imagine que maxime il sera pour
essayer de rajouter une ligne à son
palmarès c'est une belle ligne c'est une
belle ligne champion du monde de blitz
est pas
anecdotique d'ailleurs magnus chaque
année il va il va défendre sa chance
pour avoir les trois titres qui qui qui
sont en sa possession actuellement il
est champion du monde au blitz rapide et
de et de classique mais c'est un titre
qui a une réelle valeur et donc ça si
vous aimez le les parties en rapide et
les parties en blitz ce sera donc fin
décembre et ce sera une magnifique
compétition notre hall garantie et
alireza cuisse de taupins ce coup-ci oui
allez reza ce participent habituellement
à cette compétition est lui aussi il
vise le deal ce champ sont donc on aura
deux français parmi les favoris après il
faudra se débarrasser des karl scènes et
compagnie mais et on aura une belle
chance à défendre
notre rôle belle complète wen au troll
c'est une très belle compétition
et que ce que tu vaux mieux le titre
signifie quoi seront
peut-être
oui carouge postes figurent en bas il y
va généralement parce qu'ils rêveraient
d'avoir ce titre de champion du monde
mais pour le moment ce site de champion
du monde oblige celui et charles darrow
était pas loin quand guy
chabot lévis était premier québécois
mais bon pas gagné il ya polémique c'est
un titre à mon avis qu'ils aimeraient la
nuit c'est une ligne je suis certain
qu'il aimerait beaucoup l'art ajouté à
son palmarès pour pouvoir en parler
toutes les 10 minutes sur son live
oui
est ce que j'y participe non mais j'ai
annulé mes vacances de noël pour pouvoir
le commenter c'est déjà bien et déjà
beau
nom mais son jeu sur notre source a pour
noël
faut bien une date un oui monsieur jean
vient qu'en
dépit des bois c'est quasiment pareil
aux championnats du monde de fléchettes
par exemple
s'est passé par là ouais le champion du
monde de fléchettes assez sympa
d'ailleurs
parce que je peux regarder du non jeu
suivant mais c'est juste en fait c'est
toujours c'est pas que le faire une fois
noël
j'étais peut-être des gens qui disent je
serai bien noël en famille qu'enfin
ouais mais c'est chaque année chaque
année chaque année chaque année aux
montants vie de
way après le rugby ça joue de nom mais
tout aussi partout la première chip ça
peut jouer dans certains pays cette
tradition tout en france on va y revenir
pour faire de l'audience et vendre des
trucs aux chinois mais
abc va le boxing t par exemple c'est
vraiment méchant qu'ils adorent en
angleterre c'est une tradition séquences
rapides mais je dirais tu as des gens je
pense si justes ils vont pas jouer parce
qu'ils disent bon bah oui bon après
c'est aussi l'avis d'un professionnel de
mettre les priorités là où elles sont
j'ai envie de dire
honnêtement ça me choque pas du tout que
ça joue pendant non mais c'est sûr que
ce soit toujours te battre
tas d'autres tournois ça bouge c'est une
fin c'est bien qu'ils aient un
calendrier final calendrier fixe au
contraire il faudrait que tous ils
viennent en fait tous les tournois sur
la calendrier fixe non c'est faux
nettement ça me choque pas spécialement
apprécié s'ajoutent 25 oui mais le 26
pourquoi pas après là là là où je veux
être rejoindre en revanche à 200% fab
c'est qu'ils l'annoncent mi novembre
bon là c'est vrai que tu as pu prévoir
quelque chose pour d'autres ça c'est un
peu pénible mais il faudrait que ce soit
ce soit annoncée bien bien bien en
avance
par exemple femme à mes joueurs
peut-être maxime va être enfin milan
mais ça oui mais bon après ce que si ça
joue pendant l'aïd ou quoi on est là à
dire ah ça joue pendant l'aïd je ne
reçois pas que les fêtes non mais dont
88 être un truc pas trop voilà c'est
très clair quand on connaît très bien
sait d'autre la cua ouais mais enfin
chaque camp quand il y en a qui jouent
pendant les fêtes indienne par exemple
je pense aux grands suisses y a personne
qui s'émeut parce que visitent pas jouer
à ces dates là tu vois
un
pas perdre mais je veux dire c'est mieux
que ce que ça aurait pu être contre 5,4
à l'heure où quoi peut-être
c'était le diwali ouais je sais pas du
tout ce que c'est quoi diwallit c'est
une fête indienne mais je connais pas du
tout je connais pas enfin je suis jamais
leur nom
à regret mais battre un jour on vient il
peut être sympa mais qui est purement
saisissant par son contraste aussi
mais j'avais hésité une fin j'avais si
une fois d'aller jouer j'étais rentrer
en contact avec l'organisateur tout ça
puisque plus pour que s'était pas fait
pollution et chaude ans maintenant
ces différences et internationale j'suis
pas sûr quand tu vas en chine 1 milliard
je pas combien d'habitants noël
connais pas mon avis non mais je dire
juste
en fait
comme ça dans tous les signes
hollywoodien machin comme même s'indigne
qu'on fait pas nous en fait on connaît
en fait tout le monde connaît noël
alors que ouali qu'on ne connaît pas que
ça existait pas en ce moment c'était pas
la crise et est de quelques jours
mais bon alors moi je n'ai jamais fait
avant un truc typîque américain que je
pense
bon en tout cas c'est à ce moment là
pour une fois qu'on a un truc qui se
joue aux mêmes dates aux échecs
c'est déjà quelque chose
maxime il se retrouve pas mal
de tête s'est pas trop bien trouver un
coup ce pion aux qui a avancé il a pu
l'espace il a droit plus fragiles
il n'a pas d'emprunt cas ce que
lecavalier protège pourraient avoir
envie de jouer sur ce clou âge mais pas
tout de suite
maxime est un truc qui s'est mal passé
m'ont parlé de ça passe position est
tellement bien on discute un petit peu
de hauteur du monde qui est sympa on
penser que maxime à l emporter
facilement il lui met pas la tête sous
l'eau et il faudrait
il faudrait lui mettre la tête sous
l'eau aux joueurs aux joueurs américains
donc il va peut-être avoir dû cavaler
f77
sûr car il y prend qui on prend sur
échec découvert du pion et gain de la
dame ça à faire de deux
graves mais
bon 2-2
alors est ce que c'est la pause les
entend pas et voilà il ya la petite
pause la feria ben ouais petite pose le
doigt la brume les amis la pub qui va
partir monbana pose en fait ça à 45
minutes de jeu en fait à la à la moitié
de chaque segment ok la pause aux
extraits chaque segment non mais si
après chaque segment aussi maghraoui
viendront là c'est une première pub
c'est une première page de pub qui part
donc c'est la première pause mon fab
c'est une coupure de trois minutes
voient c'est parfait
ça leur permet de récupérer en fait fab
et parce que c'est vrai que c'est assez
éprouvant de jouer des matches aussi
long et donc ils ont ils ont rajouté des
bains pour le prime aux amis pour le
coup c'est fatigant
s'était habituée à une pause entre deux
parties
et là en fait dans le format autant
chaîne en chaîne en chaîne
complexe je vais essayer de
ce que
je sais pas pourquoi les scores sont
même et je peux pas c'est pas de mon
fait non non c'est pas faim oui mais bon
si je peux la rangée jeu l'arrangent
mais non ce n'est pas de mon fait
ce n'est pas de mon fait de mon fait
plutôt non
tu dis mon c
je voulais
attends je vais réussir fab
chargé mais en fait
je réfute le
designer choses comme ça
a fini le raid quoi
yoyo la fine fleur le gotha bleus ce
côté bleu
bleu pourquoi
iorio m civile a dit
oui donc ses coûts la petite pub qui
part donc ça nous met quand même assez
bien mon fab bon bah oui
et on va partir pour pour le deuxième
set
pour la france soit le bleu à la france
le plan social mais bon c'est pas
vraiment pourquoi non plus enfin des
bleus quoi son ensemble est ce que ça
existe un chemin qui monte de bullet et
non mais ce serait difficile à arbitrer
un ça vaudrait dans tous les sens ouais
sur un sur risque est réel c'est très
difficile à jouer
j'espère que
que maxime profite bien de cette pause
il en était heureux de ces pauses
petite pause au milieu à 45 minutes
c'est sûr que ça fait plaisir
omar loup alors voilà il doit être très
heureux 1
fabiano qui était un peu aller sur son
téléphone portable aussi enfants
ça se détend
côté joueurs fois que ces six minutes de
pub un fable je crois que c'est une
double oui non mais je crois je crois
que c'est vraiment une double trois
minutes en jeu je crois les amis je veux
pas faire d'erreur mais je crois qu'on
est sur une double trois minutes ça fait
plaisir à la double c'est très bien
l'avouer annoncé une double c'est une
poule
je crois non mais je crois
voilà comme ça on est on est bien sûr
voilà petit six minutes ouais c'est bien
sage et j'avais bien vu sur la pause je
sentais bien que c'était six minutes de
pause juste bien calibré pas où c'était
trois minutes je me suis peut-être
trompé
bon j'ai mis une double pour être sûr
de bien sûr comme ça ouais ouais je veux
pas me veux pas me faire avoir par par
les pages de pub après ça me retombe
dessus donc voilà
ce que tu penses pas que vous êtes une
page de plus en plus d'une participation
est devenu quoi à chaque fois enfin
j'espère que maxime regarde la plus
grosse moment
il ya le film spiderman on nous a dit
magnifique
donne pas des caves cet effet fab
ça fait plaisir
je sens que demain les pubs sont plus
intéressantes que la petite nul demain
il y aura enfin peut-être sur un nul
mais j'adore ce que des baux souffre à
prendre très cher
j'ai nagé un mail de la verrerie
d'empoli qui m'écrit
ils sont 13 à homs qui sont à la design
expo dubaï 2020 donc ça en ce moment en
fait ça a été décalé donc sur le truc à
dubaï mais ils sont très heureux mais
thomas mann mais ils vont m'aider en
fait je trouve que c'est pas du tout un
sens sont pas là il en fait
beaucoup même ils sont très heureux de
te dise quoi bah oui non et ils me
disent allez voir leurs verres ils sont
contents c'est italien tu as aimé écrire
italiana génial
[Musique]
j'ai envie de leur répondre ou
moi j'y serai pas mais très bien de vous
et soyez
je crois que les saint vaast exploits du
valais on se trouve aux fouilles à la
maxime j'espère qu'il ira qua non et
maxime va y aller c'est sûr
je suis sûr que c'est sympa donc j'avais
vu un peu déjà la télé ils ont pas il ya
plusieurs mois
on s'est construit et tout
s'est un jour ce qui a encore 45
secondes de pause puisque on va arriver
aux six minutes et puis je suis sûr que
ces 6000 depuis en fait je suis sûr que
c'est une pause de six minutes j'ai
senti que tu dis j'ai tout de suite su
et là ça va ça va reprendre il sera
associé sa reprendre stacy mythe c'était
chiant mais j'ai vraiment toujours sûr
je suis content parce que j'ai déjà dit
j'ai pressenti
j'ai pressenti que
que c'était simule de pub
ça me fait plaisir
non non je suis sûr que ça va prendre
maintenant d'un v6 très logique bah j'ai
toujours su je pense
je pense que je suis quasiment sûr que
c'est ça
des joueurs qui attendent que la pub se
termine
et ça va repartir
elle mettrait très bien cette pause
est ce que tu penses que au milieu du
segment bull est de 15,8 la rose 6000 de
pub
up être un simple c'est un peu dommage
mais j'espère je sais pas honnêtement ça
c'est une finesse que je ne connais pas
mais mais j'ai bon espoir il peut nous
régaler vrai plaisir
ça ferait plaisir
maillard de s'ennuyer c'est un truc de
ouf maxillo goût de sa life 2 45 me
charger quatre parties tu te bouffe une
pub de dix minutes
fabien très stoïque
s'en fout vraiment pas bien
folichon sur un diarra les mecs je
retourne aux chiottes repasser deux
minutes serre par an c'est reparti à 4
cette année explique
comment la même chose
au hockey
oui cette petite ligne avec les noires
qui semblent visuellement pas terrible
il joue mais qui joue à
fond là dedans et c'est qu'il fallait à
5 2 nouveaux maxime qui avait bien
réfléchi
réfléchit plus hein quoi il revient
dames c'est ça tu vas y rejoue la même
donc vous ces deux cavaliers à vii c'est
par tirage cattin
à chaque fois faut trois pattes par la
loi pourquoi pas [ __ ] c'est pas maison
statut le paquet erika iii de fausser le
marché à tous il laisse le fou en
bonne voie de fait quand même partie
c'est exactement il avait laissé le fou
aussi il était reparti vers h 4 mai
sikes avait donné des options de fois ci
ce n'est pas été jouée par
par fabi
mais fait un petit à 4 tout à l'heure je
sais pourquoi pas un trait typique quand
il est un pion b5
damned
ce cas oui
maxime chevalier passionné parce que
dépôt par le cos vide et il peut le
remplacer un bon ça
n'aura pas d'emplois ce moteur seront
signés pour la ville a choisi de bonnes
pour lui débat non mais c'était avant le
match mais il n'y aurait pas de
remplaçants lailler juste en vacances en
fait enfin
maxime est juste alors vacanciers la
droite prend des vacances maxime quand
même
ça y est une idée cacher il va quand
même il joue quand même beaucoup tout au
long de l'année maxime
profite
d'un temps libre dans son calendrier
très chargé pour un petit peu détendre
il a quand même enchaîné le grand suite
du championnat d'europe fia toutes les
phases de préparation il faut un petit
peu coupé un moment donné surtout qui va
bientôt avoir la phase de préparation
dans les coupes bien leur offrir joueurs
en écran prénom a bien sûr du monde 2007
qui va vouloir jouer quand même et ça
c'est tranquille ce qu'a toujours
mais la raison de coupes et bien il faut
il a tout à fait raison
il a tout raison
alors et quand ces invasions ça sent le
second temps mais s'il était second
temps il n'aurait pas écrit qu'il était
enfin juste parti après quatre jours
non mais je sais pas quoi vous dire quoi
on a déjà répondu en fait est déjà ça et
il faut pas tout le temps on retire le
même truc
après je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
joueurs d'échecs qui ont été invités qui
sont allés là bas et ça lui permet aussi
de voir des potes etc enfin oui ptête il
fera un coup d'envoi d'une partie où
j'en serai pas
car il connaît peut-être des gens hors
échec aussi à dubaï ça existe
vacances à dubaï face comme un bel
endroit
puis à l'exposition aussi comme on le
disait bon dans cette partie on parle de
maxime fait famille on joue un peu
pareil bon il jugé ce à
quoi
j'ai 5 g catway
frêche n'est pas la position des noirs
aux longues c'est peut-être pas
exceptionnel mais en blitz est vrai que
c'est pénible à jouer avec les plans de
squaw valley à vii qui blindent ouais
tiens je cite un tweet et d'affaires g5
g5 g4 qui part homme et un potentiel
pour le noir dans son genre position
qu en bits c'est sympa à jouer parce que
tu attaques le roi adverse tu cliques à
fond
pour 18,3 du coup maxime a empêché g5
via fourrage 5 du genre paris du coup il
repart ici est un genre de statu quo
cavalier f1 mais il se replace moi
j'aurais fait ça tu vas où tu ranges et
trois non cela
un petit rang le trois jours
fous g5 s'il n'a pas fait tout à l'heure
et changer les leaf ou
vraie grossesse à sa joue un mais cinq
c'est plus facile de cliquer avec les
noirs pour le moment mais là je sais pas
ce que tu veux mais sa feinte a pas de
coups évident non plus finalement au
pire tu fais statut cotées comptant au
noir statu quo tu es content
après tu tu as du mal organise un truc
genre b 4 c 5 kg 5 6 des cas je pense à
thiais arrive pas
à surtout quand tu veux qu'on tranquille
pour 3kg 500 turquie et des cinq ça tu
prends puis on prend un cadrage avec ça
la case
après à vrai dire surtout prendre il
peut aussi avoir des pions prend un
engrenage
si tu as fait b 4 c 5 je veux dire même
si non tu auras pas accès à 2,5 pb 4
pour notre logique
du coup ils menacent haute vous prend
prise prise prisé prix initié
il ya le cavalier donc magna dessinera
vraiment qu'il va prendre voilà mon cas
il prend j'imagine
près d'am prend aussi une option
je crois que ce qui n'est pas excessif
en f1 si nous mais bon peut-être à faire
dame prend pressait de s'infiltrer par
l'album parfait car à lesperon aussi
bientôt reprendre
il va pas du tout autre sens
est-ce qui va faire ses 5 est ce que
j'avais demandé et du coup peut-être
tour bouge et qui a valu à trois qui a
aidé 5 mais peut-être frafu prend prends
parce que face à qui thaçi s'est
peut-être pas cher c'est un peu double
tranchant
en fait il faut vraiment fait rien avec
les blancs parce que les noirs ils vont
avoir un plan à long terme ces genres si
si
les dames tu fais affaire tour à 8 à 5 à
4 c'est toi qui émettent de la colonne
as-tu pour apprendre tour à trois
rentrées dans la mère d'accueil la table
on fout contre mauvais fou quand on fait
donc
ok faut faire hier mais bon t'as qu'à
l'e3 qui avaient des cinq
avocats relief 3 kg 5
tu veux dire c'est un peu
contre sens
non mais ça doit toujours aller mais je
veux dire je crois pas que les noirs
souvent bien tord g8 de ce cavalier
c'est une incroyable refait mais il se
touche tout les cas ce qu'il faut
peut-être
la qualité terre tu craques
je ne sais pas mais peut-être ça se
regarde quoi ce film qui arrive trois
qui a été 5 kg 5 est apte à cassis
un peu partout
donc du coup ça tue un peu de sang l'air
et je peux faire un 4 avec les blancs
genre tu bloques
dénoncé une menace en tête photo j -c
menacent la tente a certainement il ya
même ainsi à plus de pièces talent pion
à droite arieh des français a baissé à
ba2
j'ai perdu comme ça contre tomaszewski
en longues
non mais c'est terrible j'ai pas du tout
vue l'idée en fait ça a été mis en place
de loin bon quand c'est arrivé j'ai vu
mes bons trop tard trop tard mais moi je
visais wilko est mon con il fera 7
réseaux industriels autour des musiques
où est ton coup il veut faire annuler
oui faisons nos bombes après quand ça
arrive et elle vient donc on me prévus
aux photos
voilà le truc c'est qu'en plus il peut
jouer d'un côté avec j faty poteau
monatte regard des cavaliers 1 je vous
sens tous les azimuts et regarder les
deux tours qui sont faites elles tapent
dans le canal
ouais en fait je sais c'est improbable
fait les pièces blanches je tape dans le
cheval mais le cheval est impressionnant
fait il tient la position bichari quoi
bon bah c'est un genre de ces kiss et un
petit-fils tana 3 avec on avait quoi on
avait une main de la justice hier on a
fait très très mal avec cette triste and
away très fort que
nous convoquons de weyer eh bien quoi là
bas on a une belle compo un
navet une très belle compo
choix arrive en face à et karim c'est un
cheval mais il n'est pas dans ce set de
tft est-ce que c'est pas un broom quoi
ce qu'ils veulent c'est fait un bronze
c'est peut-être un messin brome 2
minimum bon c'est le brome a disparu
mais au prix de sniper ouais
elle a fait mal aux lignes arrières
mais bon ça va échanger les dames les
karim tu es blanc va revenir va c'est le
brome quoi le bon mode vert sauf à l
on joue à tft sur un seul compte ah ben
on découvre hausse + cave qui joue moi
je loge je vois tu kiffes 1 je suis là
mais je veux dire je clique pas quoi oui
mais gères tu commence à apprécier mais
de reconnaître les bonhommes tu commence
à apprécier et première partie c'était
dur mais tu commences à hâter la cua
chercher dit m on est là quoi
j'aime pas le sac de qualité ouais mais
c'était peut-être un peu obligé en fait
si tu es en longues enfin quoique même
même si c'est donc très content que
non mais il est pas bien maxime mais la
pointe d'une pratique c'est chiant à
convertir mais c'est pas si simple tasse
et mieux ça que l'autre position où il
va la même chose et de thor qui vient
d'ailleurs si vous faites un parallèle
magnus avec la qualité de moins dans la
partie 2 il était pas bien non plus et
sa boîte à bulles on sait enfin c'est
lui qui jouait le gain j'exagère mais
c'est lui qui s'est retrouvé mieux non
plus parce que c'est pas évident avec
une qualité de plus quand les chevaux
font mal aux petits blocs les castes et
tourner nos colonnes et puis c'est bien
ils ont des cases pour eux
un truc c'est qu'il tient en tout cas il
est comme le cheval henri vii en fait il
tient tout un miroir f3 il veut quand il
veut tout réussi c'est peut-être bien
joué ça de maximois je peux te
retrouveras sangokuden le pion de pas
beaucoup mieux
d'arrêter pas bien longtemps j'ai pris
froid new way
bas c'était très mal en fait non ça
c'est attaquer tout à fait retour g6
c'est maxime qui va être mieux
moi 3 et si on prenait des qpr en g2 est
en fait un peu par mois et qui avait les
f-5
c'est compliqué je suis lent ce qui va
prendre en fait il va liquider non non
il prend la
bombe à leucate pour tout reprend bétail
fait très chaud
a bien joué tour 3 termine bien fou roy
g7 sur fx est fou j'ai sicile à roy
prend
maxime qui met en place un
f6 cf cette fuite non ya pas de tours à
huit
photos même tout seul et on a senti qu
elle mettait des pièces bizarre il faut
f3 way out our g8 l'échec et damman très
bien joué de la part de maxime a bien
tenu bien que la qualité il a senti l
aspect pratique est non il après on ne
peut s'en vouloir perdre ça quand même
ouais non il peut s'en vouloir bien sûr
mais
on a on a senti la position tourné en
faveur de maxime et autour j'ai trois
fois je crois mais c'est un truc c'est
que t'as pas assez tendue sanctuaire la
médina baye il ya trop de pièces en or
mais tient cloche qui partent attaqué
par rennes où est
donc
peut-être qu'il aurait dû à mon oeil
justement de la calloc'h est un peu
comme des pots quoi ouais finul et puis
nul mais c'est difficile à de faire ce
choix maxime on sait que c'est son jeu
hein c'est là qu'il est vraiment plus
fort que fabien henry arrive senti soir
voilà ça sourit un petit peu
annonce à juhasz à jour amal
famille qui sue à
presse fabi c'est tellement pas son jeu
quoi fin je trouve que tu fous
complètement
isolée de faire de son mieux voilà sa
piste c'est vraiment pas son truc sa
famille son délire c'est bref les chars
long pour moi c'est ça
c'est mais il le fait bien c'est de
passer des peaux font fuir à calculer
c'est beau c'est un anti néo pourquoi
ouais alors servir ce n'est pas vrai
voilà je vois qui suivra il souffle
[Musique]
bah c'est pas trop le passé pour max il
va échanger en d4 un jour matin à mener
un truc sur des cinq
d'être des cds qui a et b 4 donc le dis
quand même
ouais mais tu dois faire enfin ça dépend
si si maxime lui faire et fiat ouais ça
va ça va partir ça va faire mal mais bon
pour l'instant et 15,4 à surveiller et
peut-être avec les blancs si tu fais
une affaire qui le 3 6 4 mais ça aussi
c'est dur à mettre en place
un jour
mais oui c'est fou quand même quelques
parties rapides sont vraiment bien plus
intéressante à regarder qu'elle est
parti donc j'imagine chez soi ou
ailleurs si on avait une compétition
avec un enjeu à quel point ce serait ce
serait cool quoi très clairement lie
c'était un quart de finale en 1 8e de
finale de championnat du monde ce serait
le feu
et on verra pas tout à fait les mêmes
positions à mon avis fabre se seraient
pas les mêmes d'ouverture et les mêmes
coûts mais bon c'est pas la peine de
[Musique]
ces justes pour dire que même là déjà
c'est kiffant à suivre donc imagine si
tu fais la même chose avec
nos maisons avec quelque chose au bout
quoi à dire si souvent cours mais se
fait plaisir quelqu'un remarque oui oui
ça
tours 8 en revanche la tension pour
maxime de pas le premier qui pousse va
faire mal et la fabia non il est pas
loin quoi mais pas moins à risque caspar
f3 c'est un thème il peut faire
peut-être un jour peut-être des vins
d'ailleurs je sais pas mais
vous êtes arrivé si ce qui est prompt à
5 j'imagine il est vite et bien après
c'est vrai il couvrit si
l'armée un bronze
elle peut prendre sur échec
logiquement
doubler par les pions brave la colonne
bec mais
après ce bon est-ce que s'il attend de
faire tourner un ça va être cool après
peut-être que maxime peut jouer b6 en
amont
maxime qui envoie ses shows vas-y 10,5
mais en fait tu vas te faire beaucoup en
ce sens qu ils étaient huit à dix
j'aimerais bien vite des cinq soirées
c'est très bien joué de la part de
maxime
si on avait dû glisser en voiture en jeu
savary vachement important ça
l'ouverture non bah ça c'est un truc une
nouvelle fois on a beaucoup et on dirait
que fava cette question mais je profite
de ce format là pour leur faire au
contraire plus on accélère les cadences
- l'ouverture à d'importance parce qu'on
ne peut pas mettre en place des normes
prépa c'est trop dur de se remémorer les
fichiers dans la tête et donc on essaye
plus de privilégier des positions
agréable à jouer du nautic de jouer
pratique et donc au contraire les
cadences rapides ps l'importance de la
prépa même si la prépare est importante
à mes gens regardent la partie la partie
de ce match là où maxime avec une miss
clic 3 au premier coup sec agri plus
facile et gagne facilement emails ni feu
trois parties lentes
à barbery n'aurait rien donc
[Musique]
herman
ce que me
alors trop bien il a tenté un truc eric
le 5 pourquoi pas on va d'ailleurs mais
c'est pas trop bien goupillé pour lui il
est pas trop bien mais après puissance 4
il a gagné
t'es sûr après
d'ailleurs oui c'est intéressant les
deux fous sont bloqués
mais du coup ça joue un peu le foot et 6
contre le cavalier et le pion plus et ce
avec le pion en c5 va être super mais
lorsqu'il appuie le fou quoi parce qu'il
irait le fou va va être annulé la foule
machin ça était si tu fais fouet fuite
vous prendrez 6 va a les blancs sont
très contents
bon après la menace qu'elle prend ses
cinq honda me 3 ou dame b 5 pour essayer
de choper le pion c'est tendu comme
position non ces avantages landais
miaulant étaient masqués français 5 et
encore du jeu quand même pour max ouais
c'est pas fait assez juste mieux blanc
mais c'est mieux au blanc mais sans
trace en plus c'est mieux au goudron
mais c'est pas désespérée il a bien il
sait bien réorganiser la avec cavaliers
ou six fois et fuite il a vite vite
remarqué que le pion s'est s'inquiété
emprise visuellement tu as l'impression
que c'est qu'il ya 5 pouces et 5 mai
n'est peut-être pas le défendre mais ça
c'est pas con il veut laisser 15 et 20
pouces ramener quoi ils jouent ffr fous
ces 4es et jouer sur la mappe pièce
c'est ce qui fait le plus tôt peuvent
donc qui menace tous ces quatre ici mon
max peut faire rage suite et décalé un
way point peut-être dû aussi enfin non
mais c'est juste pas simple présent
quand je dis non c'est pas 100 meilleurs
maximy il peut voir
il a trouvé ça tape intéressant quoi
ils à trouver le bon set-up et on n'est
pas étonné un maxime il est vraiment
vraiment très fort pour pour ces petites
choses là
c'est le boss du blitz c'est un des tout
meilleurs glisseurs du monde à maxime il
doit être top 5 mondial pour sûr après
il est bon magnus carlsen hikaru
nakamura l'iresa fille roja nepomniachi
mvl je pense sont les cinq joueurs que
tu cites c'est un peu le quinté
du blitz après c'est dans l'ordre ou
dans le désordre sûrement moins
justement à mai mais
le mec qui fait chaud c'est ma mémé si
jamais en fait
non je mets ma mais si les choses oui
mais sur un tournoi majeur si mais quand
même bien l'intrigué tout cas une époque
qui m'ont ils dit maintenant
on dit nyan win htein win un
chien basile dans le top 50 nissan
m attention aux noms que l'on cite dans
le tchat non mais sa bombe deux soeurs
non parce qu'il a gagné le match de mélo
vitesse mais les politiciens aussi
j'aurais peut-être gagné en fait
si mon adversaire est pas d'algues into
par forfait bombe à un moment et à
wesley so aussi qui peut être dangereux
n'est plus sur internet il a il a moins
de références sans réelle wesley
quoique il a game grande chaise tour
pareil non mais il peut faire
pour avoir très très compliqué il a
trouvé un truc sympa il défend la casse
et 4 comme ça c'est bien celle qui est
un cadre que de revenir je sais pas où
se faire clouer
ok il veut faire c'est 4 c'est ça qui
émettent le fou et c'est génial wysiwys
j'ai perdu le pion et ça me permet de
protéger bien joué de la part de fabiano
ce concept l'a21 c'est chaud c'est
intéressant ça joue pas mal sorti c'est
une belle partie
sacha guitry le triple champion du monde
au blitz clairement mais non mais c'est
comme si notre époque c'est ce que me
son site kasparov atteint mon but ce
n'est pas qu'ils me donnent un peu moins
bon
toutes proportions gardées un sacha et
encore et encore là encore actifs mais
le calcul moins vite duquel
ses plus grands chercha qu'on a qu'on a
pu connaître ici la dame peut
éventuellement se glissant b6 pour
préparer dès cet été notamment via la
poussée
je suis un sur trois tu regardes à 5
étoiles et d'un peu tous genres sur tous
ses sites à cette dame moi je pense
qu'avoir sur les découvertes mais aussi
d'un point à 5 regarde non mais ho trust
juste envie de plus le voir sur le coin
battue au sial en b3 du
hilal et imbécile et si ce que j'aime
c'est que fin tu crées une menace
directe c'est surtout ses six d'emprunt
3 donc maxime qui empêche la menace de
mettre une pression sur des six mètres
un fou 2 pour refus de voir on s'est
trouvés souffler ouais je peux enfin
complexe un complexe c'est une belle
part prétendument puisque si maxime la
gagnant contre il mène 4-2 et et il va
pouvoir commencer à installer son jeu en
fait un peu logique ou g2 tu veux ta
main même si je vois hallyday mais ce
sont le jeu là y'a pas juste 17 ans
apprend b6
gaffe est ce qui va le voir pas sûr 17
n'ont raté 17 ça gagne et on a je vais
montrer on va on va revenir sur ce coup
17 bat menace ça pue on prend et sur
d'apprendre sur un toit plus on va
peut-être bientôt si je ne sais pas mais
tu es une tour de fatick raté par les
deux joueurs
maxime qui a soufflé à la caméra il l'a
vu maxime
avait 17 tu le vois mais des fois y'a un
truc en blessées quand un adversaire
fait une grosse gaffe c'est pas toujours
facile de le voir parce que tu fais un
peu confiance pour gagner du temps ouais
et puis après juste que je veux dire
c'est que c'était la menace d'un coup
donc il l'a parilla départ donc tu te
dis tiens à ce que
mais quand tu es un peu en dessous en
tactique j'ai l'impression que tu
essayes de faire un peu confiance pour
gagner du temps
bon après il est toujours mieux que rien
mais d'un truc au rythme en gagnant sa
charge contre moi tes voisins il aurait
trouvé ce qui serait oui le mec est
réglée vraiment prêt à tout moment je
vois je dois vérifier
humala tu prends et tu veux la finale
l'om
avec les blancs
que tu fais quoi tu montres leroy tombé
de haut sur ton procure des quatre
caisses et complexe
en tout cas maxime eu trop de chance
pratique
sur tours à 4 en fait tu veux tour b2b
du coup ils se gardent le temps prend
1,4 pour compte il veut
et va faire tourner de non droit ces
trois fronts tombé à ces hyper bien joué
et roy revient en d4 ouf les skis des
vins fins oui mais c'est beau ah bah oui
il est bordé c'est très gagnant non
c'est pas gagné encore
une belle tête pour les blancs mais
c'est pas gagné
pour ces trois tours 3 non tu veux si tu
peux être
on est s'ouvre g maxime c'est quoi son
plan salsa cachent quatre noms mais rien
fasse trop gagner c'est trop gagnant
mais je suis tombé
317 et arrive
3,17 c'est bizarre juste oui mais bon
vivre y retourne frioui
cette joute africaine est ce que
j'allais dire tu couvres le pion et c
'est 3b 7 6 8
donc ça c'est important en fait ce que
si maxime récupérer le pion à l'oeil
droit et passer la course aux jeux il
faisait la course et il aurait réussi à
faire nul c'est pour ça que fabiano
couvrez avec sa tour là le roi pour pas
perdre le pion et est poussé lui sont
pures adam et se retrouver in fine avec
trois tours contre roy bien joué de la
part de fario moi j'ai beaucoup aimé son
roi des 4 3 c3 la faim qui était qui
était il a vite que le sommet qui était
prêt si
je trouve ces joueurs vraiment
impressionnant dans ce petit jeu la
technique en finale ils sont vraiment
ils ont dû passer un petit moment
faire des études à lire des livres mais
ils ont le placement de pièces naturel
vraiment tellement tellement facile
sabahi côté maxime technique mais pas au
hasard
ils sont vraiment vraiment précis dont
il reste encore une vingtaine de minutes
fable danse est cadencé à 3 partout où
il va rester peut-être trois parties il
faut que maxime sorte au moins à égalité
de cette première phase de jeu et qui
lui met la tête sous l'eau en 3 + 1 où
là il sera vraiment favori
même si perd cette phase que je pense
pas on va déjà mais
il serait bienvenu mettre la tête sous
l'eau quand même bon pote bien sûr mais
pour être complètement sûr est ce que je
veux dire c'est que tu finisses de fasa
- un monde fini - que se passe-t-il
c'est quand même de finir à plus un opus
4 enfin
plus un c'est mieux que moi ça
ne tombe bien sûr
magnus né pauvre game 3 99% précision
match veut plus précis de tous les temps
en championnat alors faut arrêter avec
ce truc de précisions ça m'arrive en
blitz de faire sur une partie de 70
coups contre un adversaire on a fait 99
8 contre 99,7 juste parce que le calice
continuent dé finale complètement
nocturne aura un super coup bas mais sa
valeur en fait un sac est et le cerveau
de
ces terribles en fait un conseil mais
pour les analystes c'est de comprendre
ce qui se passe et pas juste regarder
l'ordi qui va vous dire afficher tels
que j allais une partie récente qu'on a
tous vu la finale entre firmes djalma
mais
en fait je crois que on va demander à
plein de gens ils vont tous vous dire il
fallait je veux tour f3 et fr nul et
c'est ça votre conclusion de la partie
mais en fait vous n'êtes pas compris la
finale et quand vous allez là jouez vous
allez perdre à chaque fois et jamais la
guinée à l'autre sens parce que forer
dans la profondeur des choses et
finalement quand nous la des kabyles ont
analysé ils vont pas de la tour soit
première rangée et de plein de plans de
défense à tours france frontale et ça
c'est plus intéressant que de sa marque
3-3 fallait faire parce que c'est le
coût de la vie à ce moment là mais ça
c'est la différence quand tu prépares
une vidéo entre travailler et réciter
des coûts d'ordi ouais enfin quant à
tous les gens qui toutes les personnes
qui analyse en faites sont matrix et par
lé chat qui font que l'analyse d'ordi
donc en fait plus personne ne fait le
boulot mais ce que je passe en fait je
fais ok je n'ai pas mal de coups reçus à
côté j'ai des élèves ils montrent leur
parti dit ouais mais là j'étais bien
j'ai juste raté ce coup en fait on s'en
fout en fait fin c'était pas ça la
partie quoi
c'était pas juste un coup un moment ci
se passe beaucoup d'autres choses et ce
qu'il faut c'est comprendre avec des
mots en fait ce qui se passe être
capable d'expliquer et verbalement plus
que dire il ya un coût un moment
mais je pense je pense que ça vient
aussi de déconvenues qui sont proposés
ou en fait comme c'est la solution de
facilité que tout le monde est très
heureux de l'ordi en fait plus personne
sans battre alors 10 à 10
et donc voilà ma news en fait évident il
a fait une grosse précision de la partie
puisqu'il a pas joué un coup donc il a
suivi ce que tout fichu ou lilas ou je
ne sais pourquoi lui a dit il a hyper
bien préparé mais tu es très précis il
connaissait hockey jusqu'à faut aussi
c'est la poussée des cinq après bah y'a
plus qu'à bouger leurs ouailles faire
nul après quoi comme ils l'ont fait en
fait il n'a pas joué donc on peut pas
dire mais enfin banon n'a plus à la
partie parfaite mais
oui mais après à progresser en plus ce
pour revenir sur le truc de caps si tu
joues des finales nul pendant longtemps
sa tour avant de rentrer le carthage en
fait suite à mu avait une partie où tu
as une finale en ont donné deux rois où
tout est bloqué et où tu peux juste
bouger ton roi pendant cinq ans deux
coups house caps 99,8 a fait très
attention à boyle elle aurait joué
peut-être remonter oui il aurait pu
monter il aurait joué là leur finale
complètement bloquée pendant pendant 49
coup ils ont eu encore un une meilleure
évaluation donc ces voix là c'est un
outil à vraiment prendre avec des
pincettes
pas la meilleure partie des stars du
championnat du monde
mais ça a été vendu comme ça j'ai vu sur
twitter
bon en fait ils vendent beaucoup de
choses à mes yeux c'est bien d'avoir un
esprit critique des fois quand il
raconte n'importe quoi j'ai 24
donc maxime qui est retourné
afin qu'ils racontent n'importe quoi
mais c'est que le moindre truc qui peut
faire buzz et s'est amplifiée fois mille
a pu voir ça sur twitter oui non mais si
j'ai vu sur twitter mais enfin de quoi
on va tomber c'est extraordinaire
[Musique]
oh ça c'est joli temps pour un f3 bon
ben
ça veut sacrifier des qualités quoi il
va bien ces quatre clairement au
aaa
a joliment
la cale et qu'ils aillent est content à
la regardent le petit très heureux il
est 13 heures mais c'est pas sûr qu'il
soit mieux non merci à toi s'est
engagé dès de qualité d'ailleurs je vais
préparer tout à fait deux tours prend
des six questions à faire ils trouvaient
trois jeunes bougent pas ma tour dégage
tu vas faire
magnifique
mais bon ben bongo était 13e ses
qualités on a fait le même boulot on va
tomber en même temps combien
bravo louise
tracé personnage fait une partie du
chemin est ce que tu as vu la vidéo sur
vitrine facile du coup louis
champion du monde qu
intéressant cette position j'arrive pas
à l'évaluer fait l'option 2 pour ça que
les blancs sont mieux mais toi tu sais
juste visuel four b3 ouais ça faut faire
et après peut-être fausse filles
touchent
quand même un truc le chanteur fait fit
médailles plutôt
bon va le perdre on va te soutient
j'ai l'impression que falluja là il peut
tenter regarde damas sept tours ces deux
oui
le tour se demandent en irak roland
fourgs yves lévesque d'albi cinéma est
toujour ces 2 qui débarque d'enfer tour
f1
s'activent granier meeddm elle a
peut-être ça maintenant d'un coup ça une
tête de mieux pour les noirs les têtes
auraient dû fuite dams est en cours ça
peut être n'importe quoi
marrant cette partie encore une fois
monté depuis tours 2 du coup
tournoi non pour maxime
f faire gaffe quand même pour certains
doit faire rage 2 après des kits amène
un truc un f4 de foot des six tours le
bouger ces dames m6 qui arrive
un peu fixé quoi enfin dernier sud en
effet tour 2% à 3 h
2a dessus reçoit ensuite damas six dans
mafia james allard f3 il y aura tout
raté à bord mais ça va sûrement le voir
vous allez voir un petit calcul vite
pour ces 8 300 spots autres ça c'est
contre sens il va empêcher toute fuite
en fait oui bon ok tu peux pas si contre
sens que ça du coup même mais lloris a
fait moins peur attention de commencer
par tour ce mais peut-être suite oursins
gelé quand je
skie est pas fou il va faire hi5 non ça
donne des cases horwath aller au flou et
à tout le monde 5 c'est logique les
diffuser quatre vies de tous ces va
traîner ce conseil mais très souvent au
blitz bon c'est un cheval et un poussin
plus loin toujours très bien mais en
plus c'est un bon coup injuste une
limite le foot en optant pech rouge et 4
tu prépares coups de beats rh 5
bon je voulais trouver très chiant
dam des quatre
générations que maxime il est infernale
dans ses positions dans les calculs vite
tu accuses vite il va vite les petits
tactique qui peut te planter
attention pas sans lendemain comme
feeling d'amour f4 fait mal mais elle
est très difficile à mener oui mais
c'est pas sa faute si je n'ai pas très
envie le wind mais d'un côté peut-être
d'ampeils mesdames des quatre en fait
c'est ce que tu fais beaucoup
adam et cash est-ce que tu touches un
peu de baisse est quand même dans un cas
un peu vrai t'as un peu d'âme bessette
danton rennes jusqu'en même
si tu fais quoi avec les noirs je dors
des 8
mai car dans un vis-à-vis à l'action
ouais mais je vais profiter stockholm
c'est ça
je sais pas ce que
après c'est pas toi qui joues en
retournant complètement
fois choisissez france 5 dont
il faut prendre
adams adam g 7 bat mais je dis ça
c'est terminator et maximilien
supportable ans et plus
c'était sûr que ça se passerait mal pour
fabi
d'abandon ces notions plus tu rentres
partout
pour dc
attention quand même encore un retour
des six à la force que tu arrêtes al dam
des quatre
jours
même si cette c'est malin
parce que surtout réussi sur cette fois
alors que ce prix
j'ai trois j'apprends peut-être
interpète
l'amener 4 bien joué un très bien tu
défends tout est bien
pour de cette menace
et a bafoué 64.6 systran
d'un printemps qui veut quoi
à mon tour des salles bien joué
il a il avait un truc je sens qu'il
avait un truc d'une fuite non il y avait
un piège de marleau grossistes dame
prend tout reprend fougeux des six fils
je crois qu'il fait froid railgun brice
que c'est vraiment gagnant ça mon fab
oui tu as fait à 4,5 ou f4 f5 28 y aura
droit mais faut juste on veut faire
bouger 4,6 enfin tu fous l'endroit gecas
a pas tort de pions prompt à wii prend
pas dû plonger a pu en première rangée 5
qui tue c'est peut-être fixé mais oui
bien joué à mashteuiatsh j'aime bien
mais c'est pas si simple a terminé non
mais faut encore h 4 h 5 ou je sais pas
quoi mais attention ne pas perdre des
deux ans puisque c'est superbe et de
après ces douches couteau
est tu sais qu'il n'est pas facile de
me sevrer
mais maintenant ils menacent
were g8 et
ya un piège maalouf
il ya une idée de marloux mais on l'a
pas vu c'était aussi je sais pas ce que
c'est mais y'a un truc en fait c'est du
pur bluff hier c'est magnifique vous
êtes maxime qui accueillit que cinq au
hasard
et qui a bluffé tout le monde
défend je obligé de prendre wash 7
ckoi c'est à 200 tours deux missions de
ouf je sais pas ce qui se passe là bas
la vie puisse pris 0,55 ses droits au
nom si vous faites tous les pions [ __ ]
incroyable la partie ouais ok voilà faut
juste cliquer et wav son entourage 5 le
prêt à la tvh très mauvais d'ailleurs il
prévoit
à la sara clique n'ont même pas un piège
ou non je pense pas
ça clique un
oui mais je trouve que c'est curieux
mais là tu j'ai en fait tu pouvais pas
faire et c'est pour ça que cette
belle partie belle passe d'armes entre
les deux hommes ouais ça l'a été julien
west bay 2 vaches à maxime karrikia qui
a réussi à sauver les meubles quand même
après puisqu'avec le pion à deux tout
d'un coup il était proche de perdre le
temps dans ces classes et maxime noir et
qui a joué passé nage des enfants fait
donc grosso limo
d'accord c'est des belles parties sa fab
ça c'est vraiment la plus belle la du
match jusqu'à annuler des trucs tactique
comment ça ne vous fait pas trop 5,6 de
qualité et le foot français 5 le machin
lepreau 5 la dame bessette les atours c2
les pièges de marley que le fou prend b2
fabiano qui vous il va échouer le piège
comme un fou je ne sais pas c'était beau
quoi le 5 août à lille et son premier
dauphin pourquoi tu joues on sent quand
même l'impact psychologique un impact
maurane de maxime sur ses adversaires il
fait peur même ou alors ils auront un
truc fabien je sais pas
j'ai quatre
jours il va prendre son sens bizarre il
revient bah je sais pas si je trouve un
compromis
je trouve pas que ce soit mal pour le
bon jean pression toujours un peu nu
pour les blancs quand même
tata perdre fou le problème c'est que
tout est bien bloquée mais si un jour ça
s'anime que tu fais du f 5 ou un truc
qui s'ouvre ça va aller mais un bon
contrôle au centre de blanc est
pas si ça demande un vrai côté non mais
des fois tu as un plan ces derniers 5 g
5 g 4 oh c'est bon je sais comment
parler mais bon le caillou de 8o germi
kg 3 mais
moi je clique quand même et j'ai trois
jours revient mais il a fait 1,5
après bush en fait
venir bout pour exposer les pions soit
tu fais des bon pas là tu peux plus
l'air mais soit usées des eaux et la
station pour y soit tu prends est faite
allées de tourny colonnes et tu tape un
peu quoi tu cliques
moi aussi je
veux vraiment g5 g4 mais je sais pas si
c'est très bizarre on
sait quand tu fais g5 ya pas toujours kg
3 kiev 5
je sais pas si c'est l'énigme atik mais
bat soissons il va cliquer un ses
membres ce qui là lui aussi le cavaliere
et 7 de femmes anne féray gym est ok tu
as donné une très bonne idée je suis le
même je te fais un gros mot ces deux
compos
belle compo qui s est soudé c'est tu
as là où il ya plus de temps d un vrai
four b3 ya pas de bécasses adam prend à
trois importants
ok il faut qu'il va atterrir en b3 non
bon
sak i corte pas mal côté maxime les
pièces de fabiano sont bien chaud
les plats les c'est tellement dur à
jouer il regarde ses deux chevaux ils
sont sous vêtements à lille et parler
d'eux de punto n'est pas mal h 4 h sinko
enlevé gysi servant lacazette saint
josse qui veut faire h 5 g 5h demain
faute ici revient que le matin.ch de
[Musique]
f3 faufile fabiano la d5 bien jouer de
maxime pons qui mais c'était 5 très bien
joué effrayante
aussi elle a évité des quatre ans à
éviter tu l'as eu des 4 mai avec le
front rows
des quatre ans soit ça nous terrorise
pas mais garde le fou c'est un peu
chiant
alors il reste 5 40 1 ce sera sûrement
la dernière partie du oui du segment
fabre c'est juste un petit petite
information importante
c'est quand égalité parfaite pour le
moins entre les deux hommes travaillent
me trouver et me dans un match assez
équilibré un final sympa en fait ouais
ouais je sais plus quoi
chaque clic c'est vraiment le résumé du
match
trop kg 4 enfin pas trop maintenant mais
ça pourrait être une idée aujourd'hui un
jouet d'âme des uns de la part de fait
qui vient toucher la tour et qui donne
et qui se donnent du cachet 4 dans son
règne et kg 4 qui avait lieu trois
cavalières 5 1 les amis c'est donc
daniel
c'est dans le daniel et beaucoup de
trous
sur mon énorme bonhomme
allez faut que max ils nous sortent un
tour de magie c'est un beau cliqueurs
maxime
il faut qu'ils envoient le joueur
français ce serait bien quand même de
tourner au moins à égalité
après fabien ils feront confiance je
vois rita lien qui servent en fait ouais
ça peut
pas se faire enfoncer en trois plus un a
priori mais bon après avoir médias je
regarde le match racing de bordeaux 1re
mi temps tu dis
rythme en fait pas du tout à un point
donc attention attention ces matchs
sur kg 4e maxime est encore floue prend
dame prend et d'un pro b d2
surcharge peut-être fire va commencer
par foulée 4 et puis mon tour compris
les cadres donnent le pion mais si le
donnerais mon
battue et retour un tournoi
assez terrible
allez faut serrer le jeu là dans tous
les cas il faut aller jusqu'au bout du
temps on sait que c'est une cadence qui
favorise un pour leurs rangs le joueur
italien
là c'est la moins pire pour lui ca -
pierre pour lui
il fait le d4 nick est maintenant ok
donc il veut pas qu'il est roi mais
quand on peut y aller si on veut mais
c'est bien le cas de la part de maxime
on n'a pas très envie de gagner sauf
wave 6,5 sur un plot on a envie de
ramener ce cavalier f5 qui fait cai fait
ce qui fait cavalier f5 il est fou
préemption prend quasiment jeune il a
toutes les cases blanches c'est la dame
va venir en b3 il va taper
maxime qui prend roi g7 blinde
maintenant il ya peut-être f3 kireev
veux qu'ils aient eu quatre noms
maintenant votre jeu
pour se replacer ça peut être une option
fait je vois qu'on est très bien que les
gens mais terrible c'est que je sais
j'ai n'y aurais pas cru maxime ça
impossible de gagner 50 max
c'est tellement tu as l'impression que
tu es gagnant mais pas contre un tel à
la b5 b6 peut être intéressant pour fabi
c'est un problème contre les joueurs
mais c'est aussi votre front il fut tout
à huy et baisser c'est joli ça et c'est
en france x fuite saadi fiction des
joueurs comme fabiano comme maxime
trop tu me donnes tu peux pas aller
finir en fait c'est
ils sont beaucoup trop fort ils ont
toujours trouvé le piège de plus la
défense de plus et et tu vas pas non
plus d'un an maintenant pour venir
défendre contre et tailleurs dastros
tunique j'avais je vais bien pointé
vraiment aux quatre croates mettaient
toujours dam des cinq
victimes qui commence par là même des 5
mais là je pense qu'il va faire et tours
d2 il veut des trois
partis menacent rien
mais oui un jour peut-être caillou 3 et
je joue vraiment très bien
mais tu as et ça c'est vrai que ma tour
d'essai de détroit je m'arrête et me
merde faut trouver un autre coup ait eu
en fait ils continuent voie d'être
offert ça on va dire et je sais mais des
fois tu aurais eu raison de s'arrêter
pour gagner du temps mais ils y arrivent
en fait mais ce qu'ils vont beaucoup
plus vite que nous ouais
ce qu'on fait moins ce que j'ai vu c'est
tour ces trois ou quatre et je me suis
arrêté en fait
4 ans et 4 aussi on peut je sais pas
j'avais crié trop amochés mais aussi
utile j'ai beau
[Musique]
tas pour les détracteurs de famille où
tous les joueurs au tournant ce sont des
joueurs qui réfléchissent au lieu de
cliquer ouais c'est un petit peu ça
c'est qu'en fait par maîtrise pas assez
bien encore le clic au hasard comme en
quelque sorte
en plus c'est juste pas son ti de sa
démarche aux échecs
oui alors que c'est ce que ce que tu
écris kamba qui à ton premier cours
d'échecs
déjà clic un petit peu
de mes coups j'ai l'impression qu'il a
beaucoup trop réfléchir justement parlé
du clic au hasard
voilà ça peut être très impressionnant
ce qui s'est fait en fait non mais c'est
dur passé je vois très punk et je vois
que tu es bien et offre quelques jolis
coups et
et ça a craqué enfin toujours pas mal
mais peut-être cette histoire le bouffer
on va être mieux programmer mon club
et on nous dit c'est comme contre djoko
ça te fait jouer toujours un coup de
plus le c'est un peu ça c'est un peu
cette impression mais du coup tu arrives
pendant un moment puis tu tu exploses
quoi
tout cela s'est plus concentré plus
longtemps et c'est vraiment très
difficile et l'oeil c'est foutu mal
autant fabiano ballottant donc ça va
être la fin de ce segment 5 + 1 sur la
dernière partie obscure il est important
de cela tu vas finir sur une victoire
maxime savait vraiment way une un coup
de bambou terre alat et tu as
le projet
je voulais enlever de 6-5 pour ces six
autour si ça peut faire mal parce que ça
peut se présenter en g6 attention aux il
ya cavalli c4 qui arrive sa tête
retournée
bah si tu perds pas le pion c'est bah ça
c'était bien du coup
cavale et j'espère bien venue de maxime
dégage champions bien vu de la part de
maxime
va faire quoi faire tourner c'était un
retour en championnat et qui a rédigé
quatre est on encore le brome mais bon
on le fait pour changer cette revenir
angers c'est peut-être pour colmater
représente le groupe
tout réussit ce qu'est ce que c'est bien
joué de la part de fabiano parce que
s'ils tapent 4 il tape il tape des trois
il ya deux gros en fait le kg qui
attribue des fiefs cette île tapis tap
dois-je punto ch qui peuvent pas faire
travailler ses superbes cartes et des 3c
mort maxime à maxime qui abandonne qui
espérait peut-être une autre partie dans
la cadence s'est terminé ces familles
qui tourne devant bon d'interdire
à travailler pour maxime mais famille
qui fait plus que se défendre du coup
ouais bien joué et bien joué cette
dernière partie qui a été tendu on va
mettre une petite une petite coupure pub
bien sûr un fab quand même ces câbles un
bad buzz
cette partie qui a failli retourner non
enfin à bord du maxi de paris si c'est
ça je pense était bien jouer avec l'idée
on va remontrer 1 c'est une idée
récurrente tout repenser cette fois f8
apprises tout repenser cette découverte
il a joué sur cette idée tactique
fabiano et
maxime qui a joué un coup qui paraissait
très bons fous aux 5 pour aller cueillir
le pion mais en fait la torpille en
sociologie six tours c'est cissé et ce
décalage danger si ce qui fait mal avec
l'idée aussi f6 échec cavaliers f5 un
peut-être dans certains monde qui
pouvait exister un nom bien sûr
wen en bonne partie belle partie belle
partie fab
pour le moment les joueurs assurent le
spectacle c'est sympathique
suivra honnêtement c'est cool waggon
sakic sa clique c'est un match accroché
sa qui cote
et kapsch et tu ferais tu réussiras
organiser des formats comme ça avec avec
un vrai des mecs sur place dans une
salle avec un vrai titre homologué tout
ce serait le feu exactement ce serait le
feu c'est sûr que c'est plus
divertissants qu'un certain car msan né
peu après c'est juste dommage aussi le
placement dans dans le dans le
calendrier de cette compétition après à
titre personnel je sais qu'ils essaient
de dire comme il ya du buzz sur les
échecs c'est encore mieux de mettre
cette compétition ici moi je suis un peu
de la vie que pendant une coupe du monde
de foot on regarde pas là des matchs de
cfa mais
après voilà c'est chacun chacun son
point de vue non bien sûr d'ailleurs il
n'y a pas grand monde sur les lèvres je
te jeter un oeil au passage que je
devais tchèque un truc tu vois je pour
ce dernier les autres langues 700
personnes en russe 700 portugais 6 en
polonais quatre cent cinquante ans en
espagnol on sent pas un gros buzz autour
de l'événement mais
c'est compréhensible aussi
ouais bon ces petites journées tu
souffles
souffleuse échec tu as envie d'un petit
peu souffler pour repartir sur sur le
match de championnat du monde c'est tout
à fait normal mais c'est vrai que ça
essaie de compétition pourrait à mon
avis un prendre prendre un tournant plus
officielle parce qu'elle est quand même
assez sympa dans le format cantate que
des joueurs de haut niveau qui jouent
entre eux on en parle d'
impliquer des 30 0 on ne peut pas mettre
des têtes étaient obligés de fermer la
main mais bon il de choses
tu peux ouvrir mais si un truc comme un
genre six à huit points d'écart allez
bon c'est fini rien qu'avec out ouais
bon voilà drafté but a essayé bon t'as
perdu mais tu peux pas voir pendant
trois ans et demi je viens de faire
défoncer feng zhe 9 contre m contre 40
cents oui fans comme n'a qu'à des
matches comme ça c'est même plus quoi
dire beaucoup et beaucoup de matchs de
wesley so très très mobilisateur dans
cette compétition fabre
le format est bien quand les matches
comme comme celui d'aujourd'hui sont
serrés après tu imagines là il y avait
déjà eu il y aurait déjà sept ans
c'est arrivé c'est arrivé dans un match
car yakine dépôt je crois que c'est car
yakine qui a pris un lead genre 9,0
après le 5 + 1
de quoi faire monter non à ben ali mais
juste à bonbons
non mais une fois on avait un petit
retournement mais c'était pas des scores
aussi là on sait jusqu'à 4 500 ou
d'algues et choc mais c'était 4 5 points
mais voilà mais donc c'est pour ça va
peut-être il ya plus cette un moment tu
tu shao
par moi j'avais une idée c'était le
knock out à tout moment dans le match tu
gagnes quatre parties cinq parties
d'affilée pas 4,5 parti défier tu gagnes
le match
retour a ajouté un petit peu
d'incertitude par me défoncer tout le
monde attendait bull est vrai que tu
freines tout le match
disons que ça permet dans ces matches-là
de se dire un peu comme à la boxe au 10e
rang tu es mené sécu perd aux points bon
ben je trouve un crochet du droit et
sert sur un uppercut ya rien
c'était une idée puis ça permet aux
joueurs aussi dès le début du match se
gagne sur cas où quoi pour bar voilà
mais après le par après il y avait un
problème avec ce format là parce que
j'ai proposé mais c'est c'est plus
difficile de prévoir le nombre de pages
de pub
oui normal et sud on apprend fini
problème par de la pub
non je ne sais pas étonnant de
toussaint d'autres qui font ça partout
mais
je pense que je pensais moi tu fais
d'abord ton programme et après tu mets
de la pub des temps morts ou des trous
mais pas on va d'abord penser à la pub
et après on mettre des échecs au mieux
c'est ouais mais c'est parce que j'y
connais rien mais tu as même aux états
unis genre le super bowl ou quoi fait
ses pensées pour qu'il fait c'est tout
est adapté à la pub en fait
je suis pas américain
mais c'est beau la pub en fait je suis
très heureux de la pub ça me fait marrer
en fait moi c'est autre chose
moins on en fait de la pub à fond je
serai je suis très heureux y'a pas un
concept à faire une petite
kitchenette which only pub
rock
et magnifique caïds et un truc où 124
jamais
qui parlent mal à nous on envoyait six
minutes un
sanctuaire la pause c'est vraiment calé
sur la pub quoi c'est magnifique
moi ça me rend heureux en personne à une
réseau de génie
moi j'adore mais après
je sens qu'on est pas on n'est pas allé
je suis un peu le soleil dans ce trip
pub quoi
ça reprend quand après la pub
non mais ces six minutes après la page
de réclame
les temps morts de nba qui dure 4
minutes prendre de pause pour les play
offs et pour la pub aussi ça
insupportable
c'est terrible
à
savoir pub et
sans rien attendre en retour
serait bon en faisant remettre des pubs
sont atteintes en rien en retour en fait
je n'ai même pas pour le pour le bnf de
la pub ou qua non de pub gratuite
ça
tu démarche
chez moi
c'est magnifique
oui oui on est très heureux de tout
1,59 qui demande au chat qui vaille est
blonde et moi je crois que c'est acquis
que pour messi mais on jouera donne à
lewandowski personnes voilà
c'est ça on va te j'aime plus tout le
monde sait jamais mais
aucun intérêt je suis pas c'est un sport
collectif quand son fable de base l'idée
du ballon d'or c'était de récompenser
une équipe via son joueur fétiche
le capitaine ou mec qui éclabousse à
l'ars tu fis enfin mon époque je n'ai
pas aux extra européens mais ces tarifs
il a à un joueur de naples 3-2 et
maradona
mais
juste maintenant on fatigue est devenu
c'est magnifique bah en fait c'est u sim
patron se mélangeant de l'année en fait
c'est tu dis qu'elle me rejoint
intrinsèquement tu lui donnes pendant 20
ans consécutifs
je pense même pas une saison une équipe
où quelqu'un en particulier
je sais pas je ne suis pas y toucher
moins en moins le foot mais on s'en fout
c'est comme tu dis j'ai envie de te dire
plus tu entends parler de foot moi j'ai
envie de suivante à de récompenses
individuelles dans un sport collectif on
s'en fout mais bon ça qui tourne pour la
grande soirée
je peux te dire qu'au rugby
d'aujourd'hui pontes du monde s'appelle
antoine dupont et les français et les
français et oui et oui il est vraiment
très fort un bel effort incroyable
toulousain
et oui je crois qu'il a fait ses débuts
en top 14 avec castres le voisin blessé
au dos et au castres olympique il était
remplaçant et il avait fait quelques
quelques belles entrées il est toujours
donc ouais gersois tu as le gers ça
c'est ça parle ça le gers
l'équipe française est incroyable et on
a beaucoup dont on a beaucoup de talent
mais attention de ne pas se voir trop
beau le biais de la cohésion h trop tard
mais tu vois là on a battu les blacks
ils sont en fin de saison oui ils sont
au top de leur forme c'est pas des
blagues de coupe du monde mais pas du
tout voilà c'est les blacks en fin de
saison complètement crevé les white quoi
ils sont très forts mais faut pas s'en
faut pas s'enflammer sur ce match là bon
du coup cette partie joie que le chrono
a pas eu le chrono n'est pas partie au
bon moment maxime est ce que c'est un
peu ouais c'est un peu changé
en fait la même variante sauf qu'il n'a
pas refait fou j'ai cinq et six
mètres qu'ils allaient réviser à la
pause bon ben c'est rire je sais pas
regarder la pub un os que oui
donc la nation de souscription des
quatre honda se fout provinces trois
en arrière fond ou trois mais on peut
pas
en soi rien à
milena viens viens voir le speech s mais
pas de chance on arrêtait la publ na
waie est également raté mes romans enfin
est-ce que tu as trouvé le ton dans le
réfrigérateur
les steaks de thon un magnifique
les steaks de thon qui sont partis fab
et simcoe nord qui se laisse prendre f3
mais pour faire des ponts et parce que
j'ai trouvé béquillage 5 et 2 versions
des bonnes cases intéressant mais
peut-être que l'on peut faire acheter un
que même
certains cachent canadien qui a touché 5
ne peux pas mais c'est une idée je vois
tu veux un truc sur g3 temps vis de
l'union et le pion à jour notre arrête
et à ce
jeu-là de m'appliquer bosse tout à la
fois je
m'achèterai autres et vous savez très
grec
ferrus aussi en fait
c'est quand même de nuit dernière deux
vidéos ce hockey à 5 logis qui touche le
fou il revenir en c4
fouet trois logiques aussi développe t
rop cas il s est tous très logique bravo
je vais peut-être du cecim corée ou deux
estime claude tu veux du sinko skf 4
f406 en cours peut être logique pour ce
genre de fusée
moi j'ai un peu peur
crise prises plus tôt ces think au canon
staff et qui a aidé si cette bombe un f5
tu l'as pas il faut faire au moins
arracher d'avant mais
c'est ça ouais ok un passant
si on peut pour l'occasion mais mais bon
les cases noires et la structure en
blitz est un bon choix pratique en tout
cas je t'aime peut-être adam des quatre
maximum qu'au retour c'est de casillas
negras
ça peut aller pour ses deux autres fils
et sinko à szczecin kochi cointreau ça
peut être dangereux
virus mais non c'est dangereux c'est
dangereux fabre est objectivement je
sais pas qui est mieux mais on croirait
nouari siens
mais maxime y joue bien ce truc là
au retour c'est au tour ce
il fait c'est tellement logique
faut faire gaffe ainsi le plus raté
riant h3 ça peut être aussi être un
autre problème
relève hausse
mais ca d'apple oui
je pensais bien que c'était pettigrosso
danger ouais cpi grosse
gepi je vais pas dire n'importe quoi
je saurai
500f quattropole et adam cointrin donc
je crois que tu ne veux pas tu peux pas
te vois
tu ne peux pas
ombrage cette fois ci sinon on va voir
il faut qu'un retrait de 2 me 6 h 30 un
effet si
je suis 3e
maxime il joue très bien là et il adore
avions plus
défensives adverses avec fabien autre
impression que tu vas tu veux attaquer
maximy tu joues tout tempo et à plus d'
attaque
ok
tour des huit
une avance quasiment
maxime là il est vraiment incroyable fed
explique très bien pour ceux ci sont
jour qu'est ce qu'ils jouent bien là il
a complètement retourné l'attaquent il a
gagné la casse des cinq étapes enfin ce
brave homme ça paraissait dangereux et
c'était dangereux quasi sûrs
et a rendu son signifiant que dit on
attaque mais en plus en jouant thème
faut enfin faire par là que cette
déposition qui sont dures à jouer avec
les blancs voient l'une il a joué plus
vite que fabiano et plus fort
c'est incroyable maxime il est vraiment
incroyable pour ça
c'est pas pour rien que c'est un des
tous meilleurs bosseurs du monde 1 ça
c'est très difficile à faire en bits ya
peu de personnes sur terre qui sont
capables
icaro peu de faire ça
intellectuel
white the white lies bête
mistake
franchi aucun seuil
sting ou à turbines dit ata est surpris
au tient un fusil n'a pas joué du tout
sur les 4 je tiens pas vu une vari
vantant 24 coups à la fin qui est un peu
moins bien
mais attention quand même parce que la
laddh hier ces risques ou avec l'attaqué
dès lors quoi ouais team is one case bon
ok autre fusée a quand même
genre fou prend b2 je trouve de 5 un pur
appât c'est toujours ça sent to re 2
j'allais dire tu en prends des cinq as
il veut pas tomber deux joueuses et elle
veut fou des quatre fêtes il veut gagner
à f2 oui mais c'est pas bête ouais
ok bien joué mais non c'est bien joué
parce qu'en fait tu aurais zot le roi
est à peut-être des perpète dans leur
âge tu as tous rêvent de toi
mais qu'est ce que c'est dur à voir ça
au le malaise
non mais ça c'était mais perdure je
crois tu peux quand même tenir un
clanwar non
mais comment tu fais tu vas pas te fais
enfin à leroy va tu vas jamais plus ça
en fait n'avait plus foulé pions man tu
mènes pourvoi dans le trou
tu perds 3 et tu forces un truc ans
je suis pas sûr j'ai 5 contre sens c'est
peut être ok bon il faut tout reprendre
ton genre oui mais bon enfin oui on s'en
fout des cinq grandes villes
je laisse un goût bizarre quand tu as
histoire 5 quoi ouais
moi j'ai trois
fois maxime quévy fabiano 6-1 le foot et
qui à tour d2 le cavalier aux trois
fours 3 tours 5 mais ces rois f3 c'est
n'importe quoi la vitesse à laquelle ils
voient ça c'est un truc de malade
toi un nom
à toi on croirait cedro sa
tombe et 6,3 à ses sept
tours à 3 tu touches à
368.1 jouer puis j'ai 4 qu'est ce que
c'est bien joué ah ben non ça c'est bien
fait de la part de max je veux aussi
roi prend
je défends comment tour à 5o un [ __ ]
que c'est bien le tour h 5 h deux temps
reprend est tombé 5 euros à la mélasse
et le niveau qu'ils ont final la vitesse
d'exécution c'est impressionnant
non mais ils sont vraiment très très
impressionnante et pat
o la vitesse
c'est n'importe quoi
petercam sur maxime on fabrique il ruine
qui jouent comme sur
l'iphone 5 ne commet pas quand tu vois
aussi vite en fait
oui sont fortes et la vitesse
d'exécution et calculs vite ils savent
aussi beaucoup de choses oui mais ils
sont vraiment faim c'est sûr ils sont
forts à dire que moi je peux bosser
toute ma vie j'ai réclame aussi vite
fait c'est impossible hotz a maintenant
des vieux non mais non mais prolonger
c'est beau c'est jeu non mais j'ai
peut-être pas même différence
c'est impressionnant je suis je suis
estomaqué
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de
laisser cette heure à ses joueurs pour
bien jouer vu la vitesse d'exécution est
ce que tu t'es pas d'accord avec valve
finalement que l'intéressant aujourd'hui
aux échecs de haut niveau c'est de les
voir faire de tels projets se servent de
telles prouesses moi je faisais plus
impressionnant encore que des parties
longues personnellement parce que c'est
parti donc va étudier où il a fait une
erreur machin leur disons analyser ou
quoi mais là en fait c'est que tu tu
sais que tu peux l'exécuter je sais que
je peux trouver tu mets une demi heure
je trouve mais ils trouvent ça avec 10
secondes
avec six secondes bordel c'est
l'incroyable truc marrant c'est un
brunch times il suggère un truc un peu
comme ça fait il penser que peut-être un
jour ça débile de jose de chaque parce
que juste nul
en face à des tournois de résoudre des
trucs
vitesse ciblés machin et des trucs
compliqués et en fait c'est un peu ça
c'est à dire que c'est pas encore au
point où c'est débile de jouer l'un
contre l'autre oui on l'a d'ailleurs
mais bon là il y avait le maximum mais
[Musique]
mais mais juste en fait oui je pense que
c'est plus la prouesse maintenant que
leur maître set je suis frais c'est ça
je suis d'accord je la lâche c'est si tu
veux la séquence entre fabiano et maxime
les convient convient d'avoir dans la
dans la partie précédente je trouve ça
juste incroyable en fait
c'est dans le domaine de l'info sable
n'entend plus se bat à jouer vite soit
on peut faire en cliquant n'importe
comment mais jouer vite et bien c'est
dur que là c'était là c'était
reconnaître c'était incroyable
la défense dans la finale incroyable
non c'est vraiment et on n'a pas besoin
de faire 1960 pour ça le 960 en blitz en
vrai c'est 1 960 plus en longueur bideau
les regards
bon bah si mais qui essaie de tenir donc
il sert du pillonnage 7 comme boucliers
futur adverse c'est au travers et tient
la gazelle six mois passés sans vie d'un
mauvais fou
[Musique]
c'est une poubelle mais bon je sais pas
quand il peut tenir prenons pas aller à
il faut essayer d'être un peu de défense
et là aussi on voit un moment
intéressant c'est le moment mentale en
fait c'est c'est à dire que maxime il
avait une position qui était quasiment
gagnante fabriano il a envoyé une
défense incroyable et il fabien en fait
il a réussi à faire un truc que moi je
ferai encore incapable de faire c'est
après une grosse défense comme ça au
lieu de baisser pavillon il te remets un
gros impact bim et est maximale inverse
ça lui a mis un coup au moral et y lâche
un peu l'ouverture et fabiano est
gagnant et ça c'est aussi intéressant
parce qu'il ya une dimension l'aef
physiques et psychologiques tu vois
c'est bien là encore en moi j'aime bien
les les métaphore rugbystique c'est un
peu tes capot ouvert des deux côtés en
fait le joueur de génie tu as ta
jalibert y vient il prend le ballon vu
toi tiens je te nomme donc j'avance
j'avance quand même et du coup toi tu
étais capot ouvert est atteint
bref de quoi non plus non plus en fait
le ballon il côtoie
toiture a ajouté deux points avec la
transformation au passage c'est un peu
ça va me prendre si on prend nos
empreintes de
jouer bon mais mon tête qui prend 1,8 en
intermède
faire sens et donc en risque
bah c'est pas juste par plaisir
rien clouage en fait lorsqu'on sort dès
le 3 mai mais c'était pas n'importe qui
te donne quand même un truc d ame 3 6 1
6 1 il va y avoir des procès quel niveau
qui prend ses six fois et abandon voix
non mais c'est c'est n'importe quoi au
niveau de jeu attention maxime là il
faut pas faux pas il faut serrer la vis
un faux pas perdre celle là
mais fabien de soi solide physiquement
et ça c est marrant parce que c'est des
choses qu'on retrouve en partie longue
serre que maxime on sait qu'il a des
sautes de concentration et fabiano on
sait que c'est un monstre de
concentration et la tue on a vraiment vu
ce passage où il ya une terre un moment
à haute intensité et derrière ça fabiano
il a réussi à rester en haute intensité
maxime il a relâché pendant 20 secondes
et bah c'est un peu comme aussi toi qui
aime bien le tennis / wimbledon c'est un
moment un tueur charles atteinte et
briquets c'est qu'on n'a pas vu le
centre mais juste faire lâcher enfin un
feu qui aurait eu mille quoi dame ça va
très vite toi regarde faire des retours
de service a rendu hier il ya deux sets
zéro tu as jeté première de ces fini et
là c'est un peu ce qu'on a vu c'est
intéressant
mais forcément sastre le tennis très
souvent quand un jeu où tu peux briques
et l'autre est une brique pomme jeu
d'après attention et regarde c'est
exactement ce qu'on vient de vivre cette
dimension psychologique là qui a pris le
dessus sur sur le jeu c'était une belle
passe d'armes il va falloir que maxime
pierre serre la vis ils rejouent la même
position et la politique du maire de la
ville au 1er mai le h5 machin
objectivement ça l'est pour fabiano mais
maxime a tellement bien géré la
situation que c'est vrai que il adresse
confiant oui il a mieux joué que fabiano
il va falloir serrer la vis côté maxime
ici
et c'est intéressant parce qu'on rentre
vraiment dans le vif du sujet
je doute maxime une seule seconde il se
rêvait n'osant vite fait et il détruit
fabiano ambulatoire je pense qu'en bus
laisse le plan mais bon md de menaces
aux cavaliers provoc qui avale et prend
b3 et peut-être puis on prend et ses 5 1
pour un peu à l'image de la partie
précédente étonnant qui sociaux de ces
froids ce trajet prend pas intuitif mais
en fait on avait averti avant c'était en
fait pas si grave bon bien juger là
tellement bien géré
ses responsables ça
chez moi j'aime
j'aime pas j'aime pas la seat coup ça
ressemble à une baignoire en utilisant
du coi ouais carrément des trois quarts
b2
salue tous ces gros coup d'aller trop
d'ardeur et ça se joue juste à la
défense de fabiano je suis sûr que
fabiano ne défend pas la position il n'y
a pas le trou d'air
bondam e4 pas comme ça qu'il est prend
b2 tu veux pour ces dames
d66 grave
mais hockey est ce que b35 où
la patrouille avec les b 2 b 4 pouces et
3 donc je stockais d'être au coeur ben
oui c'est pour ça j'ai en fait ce que tu
as hâte à une triplette oui c'est bien
joué tour b15 le parti de faire dégager
les trois à quatre ans
il faut faire
le truc inverse d'auteur
avec des quatre dames bmb 5 à 4
david l'entente fou prend b2
c'est juste une gaffe au moins je vis tu
fais vite pourquoi peut-être en fait ils
pensent ils considéraient à 4 trop
graves torts francs à 5 3
allez faut serrer la maxime
apprécié non plus par ses feux piétons
fils doit prendre pour une tour quand tu
veux
arriver
des tours c3 où tour à victor à trois je
sais pas allez il faut un peu tenir là
pour maxime est de la défense
possible
cette position ouais et tu vois c'est
après moi c'est ce que j'aime quand je
suis du sport en fête
selon adam 6 et demain combat physique
et un mental mais quand ça dépasse un
peu que le cadre du sport et que tu
touches d'autres qualités en fait moi
c'est ce que je trouve vraiment beau
dans le sport personnellement donne à
tous les sports que je suis j'aime bien
ce côté là il me manque un peu au foot
dernièrement tu vois
bien jouer et maxime on peut lutter à
l'euro
à l'est de tous les côtés ouais mais
regarde non mais c'est vrai que
c'est moins moche avec ce cavalier là
que tout a un coût il se passe quelque
chose mais bon
il faut serrer
si la contre en fait tu retournes ça
aussi que j'aime bien tu as quand je
sais que tu vas vite mais c'est qu'en
fait la maxime et il peut retourner la
séquence en sa faveur
tanger encore sa défense est rangé en
fait
c'est son nom provient tout ce que j'ai
vu cet abattoir vite prend
oui madame promettre aux échecs
me promettre aux échecs et dames ses
trois échecs et prendrait
préfet chine à réfléchir il va alors il
va le trouver bah oui l'abandonnent
votre abandon ou il trouvent en fait
surtout revient sur ce genre t'as pas
d'un projet un tour un tour deux baies
de anan 17 berne d'élite c'est shakin
ils à tours j'ai encore à l'épaule trop
et si le trou il retourne le match
faillir tourner la séquence
façon il na pas le en fait tout répond
n'est pas tout rose au juste
prenons
le 7e tour prend on finit
un métro dont il veut tarifs 3 oui c'est
ça fait souffler dame b3 sur tour de
roger cette roche c'est selon
bon écoute c'est pas enfin c'est foutu
mais tu as les échecs ici ou là
cliquez des techniques sakic
un bon cavalier mais non il a super bien
défendu la maxime
pour de ce type on sait très bien jouer
il va pas la perdre ça la vie tourne et
retourne le match en sa faveur
elle est hyper chantage bessalah l'atuge
show complètement avec les blancs avec
les noirs pardon mhkd je me joindrai
mais c'est chiant bah je sais pas ces
visuels c'est parce que tu voulais voir
faire
rager 8
bonjour les toits calais si vous j'ai
démâté change les tournées dame froide
as quatre attaques et
sa clique a
bien joué or ben il faut
peut-être je vais bien mais c'est pas
fait ça non mais bon m ouais attend
3 et 7
ces gagnants bon faut en finir ah oui
t'as pas mais il va y arriver à toi et
moi y arriver mais
peut-être des tours aux cadors qui
viennent au final 2 mais bon ça c'est
plus à effet entre guillemets toro 4
annonce ça peut faire mal
j'aimerais
ballon grosse passe d'armes
bon
par contre
alors je sais pas il faut pas jouer les
nageurs en fait ils veulent pas jouer
leur ouverture
oui mais bon du cajon non plus n'ont pas
à nous sortir une prépa non plus ouais
ok française synacass-ci sound qui eux
de hockey des cinq ans je donne des six
attaques b2 tomber un
bon envol et blanc sont mal développés
mais ils ont un super centre est avec
l'énorme manque des espaces dont il faut
aussi de péter tout ça fait treize 6,7 g
la dame b 5 b 4 à 5 x 6 mai des trucs
comme ça donc m6 auquel il veut ouvrir
le centre comme prévu en as peut-être cd
cd tout prend dans le 5/7 [ __ ] en
l'air la fin
donc les blancs faut faire gaffe donc il
a pris comme ça ils donnent la caisse de
saint et que mais au moins on ressort de
cavaliers et peut-être en arrive vers la
caisse 4 un jour ou moins fous 17.8 fout
là bas leur demande si ces morts pas du
tout maxime reste favori du prix restent
favoris du match en fait mais bon là
d'un coup au lieu d'être un gros favoris
60 40 pour maxime le truc c'est que le
segment il ya le plus de parties c'est
le bullet et c'est le segment où il ya
le plus d'écart de niveau et en bullet
max il peut vraiment faire + 5 + 6 et en
3 + 1 ils restent favoris il a eu un
petit passage à vide mais maxime journée
d'hier il est coutumier du fait dans un
match de ce pitch est violent moment
donné où il peine donne moi je me
rappelle son match contre paris il est
hyper bien voilà il va gagner contre
dominguez ils étaient étonnés de plus
quatre puis cinq cas ont donné sûrement
trop beau et il a défoncé au final
voilà d'ailleurs on voit la peau de
partir
mais
ouais fait caruana que les noirs rêve
dans la française il a ouvert son centre
il y avait le problème 6 effet dépensé 5
et ses deux pions sans trop aidé et il
s'est pris au sein et quelle suite il ya
un flou bas j'ai trop un plot est ok bon
bah vous fait la tourache un faut encore
gagner maintenant mais c'est juste
gagner ou quoi poursuit thierry forcée
de tous
alors juste pour dire si ce genre de
d'anomalies dans l'ouverture arrive
c'est une nouvelle fois on va on le
répète mais c'est parce que les joueurs
ne jouent pas la répertoire mais il
n'est donc
en voulant éviter de jouer leur ligne
pour pas les montrer du doigt un truc tu
mettrais au moins quelque chose qu'ils
maîtrisent moins est il quand ils
maîtrisent moins mal comme vous comme
moi comme comme fab ben ça se passe
moins bien quoi
il possible et 5b quatre peut-être et
ont baissé en quatre heures bref va
essayer de défendre car voilà mais c'est
dur parce que l'eia tourbez système qui
va arriver et j'ai trois touches le fou
et là tu ferais si je veux téléporter le
fond b3 tu tiens encore bon petit rat
sain kaka vainqueur des trucs mais oui
il faut mais trop bien tu attaques des
cinq ans plus
imaginer il veut dire partout retour v6
ou d un tour b 2-3 trois
bouffées j'ai deux
pages et de la 2 parce que d'ailleurs tu
entends judicieux de faire [ __ ] si le
poteau peut-être commencé parfois f3 la
c4 est bien entendu
un sac fabien
melocheville en soirée est ce qu'on peut
quand même faire ce qu'on a parfois f7
des tombes est ce un acte horrible je
pensais aussi ça
mais peut-être y faire je sais pas un
truc
ayvaz des cinq tours b3
prendrait 5 transformations donc très
bien vrai ça magnifique maxime way au
bond encore gagné mais
normalement
fort qu'un cavalier scorpion sur les
deux ailes on peut faire deux pions
passé ici et là après il ya un défaut
dans la position c'est que le pion à
passer c'est la mauvaise couleur
donc
caruana
je sais pas trop dans quel monde mais il
te sacrifies tout les droits contre
l'adoption et avec maxime pousse trop
vite ça peut faire nul mais là
normalement pas assez jolie ci a fait
maxime n'était pas loin de ne pas la
gagner mais
il faut en trouver des jouets des choses
pour battre ses joueurs
m tous les buts parti tu te dis bon
c'est fini c'est gagné puis en fait tu
ferais tu dois trouver le temps prend b3
et machin c'est pour ça qu'en fait quand
même lui dit nous on n'a aucune chance
contre eux en fait c'est impossible le
texte rush un
t5 j'imagine focalisation
il faudrait 10 pounds of pour gagner en
fait faut espérer qu'il fasse des
excuses c'est de faire quand on joue
contre eux c'est à dire espérer qu'il
fasse une gaffe ou quoi qui se relâchent
et après pas jouer tranquille comme
quand tu comme comme tu jouais contre un
joueur apte à fond plus faibles il faut
aussi en fait de les terminer tout de
suite c'est maxime qui va donner le
conseil d'ailleurs et ouais et en fait
c'est la seule chance cdc même quand à
trois pions plus une pièce de plus de
dix roquettes un faux organes vitaux
gagne élite en fait je vais pas
transformer jouer la finale machin
redonner un peu davantage sa marche pas
le seul truc qui marche c'est de
défoncer
il a changé italienne du qu ils
regagneront qui casse un peu la
dynamique il ya plus que 7 5 c'était
important et
ouais ok donc italienne alitalia et
fabrique avec fausse atp avec ses 5
tout se joue aussi très bien le fou est
moins actif mais t'as plus l'histoire de
clouage là bas et a pas laissé trois des
quatre trop à gérer quoi
donc j'imagine ont apprises espace qui
est des cinq ces trois
pointures comme on dit en vrai pour le
top 20 mondial il fera un autre titre
car la différence de niveau est
incroyable ah ouais il joue pas au même
genou 1
mais on le sait la même chose en longue
mais en fait on perçoit beaucoup plus en
rapidement beats
morlhon différences s'amenuisent oui ce
qu'il ya le temps de s'organiser parce
que comme tu vois pas des trucs
tu peux promettre que recalculé retour
et puis comme le résultat fondamental
d'une partie nuls si tu fais pas trop de
fautes qui arrive alors que là en fait
t'as pas le temps de s'organiser donc tu
vas forcément réaliser des fautes
missionnement c'est que la perception
inverse les gens se disent moyen de
temps plus est hasardeuse alors que non
enfin ça dépend sur une partie oui
françois malye oui on met sur
sa une partie tout peut arriver tu
prends une attaque machin tu fais gaffe
tu fais gaffe mais ballon blanc fait
saleh de faire des conneries
annoncé tour à 4
tiens bon tu joues et ses trucages et tu
as l'impression avec les litiges et les
noirs oui bon ben je vais l'attaquer en
fait y arrive jamais fin je suis heureux
des blancs moi aussi
mais avant en fait j'avais l'impression
que bongo pour les blancs soin de toi
perdre en fait pas du tout la maxime est
très bien pas déjà cédé 9,5 fait plaisir
bat a du mal à faire tout courant
de cette fois 4 donc nous dit ça fait
pas trop envie mais bon
dans la maxime où il a il a une belle
chance là faut qu'ils appuient sur
l'accélérateur et lengagne de ravir à
7,6
au tie break le premier set mais tu es
là pour la suite non non il est bien
maxime il y aura une pause a normalement
après cette partie si je suis à le
règlement
pourquoi passer six sapeurs beaucoup et
puis on prend du papillon c6 tu perdes
af c'est aussi
en fait t'as pas envie d'ouvrir le four
b3 quoi juste basiquement super derrière
mais là il est très bien mais si
en plus vers avantages autant je pense à
bien
fabiano à devoir commencer à réfléchir
pour tenir et donc ils apprendront taz
autant à la voir cliquez vite et
accentuer et la position et la pendule
ça doit le faire ta tour à cap turki
coup les autres côtés tant qu'équipe
nous ont dérangés quatre tâches 4 taplin
petite idée là bas a déjà kg 5 7 contre
106 et carnets sur son point faible les
blitz bah oui enfin c'est le cas fin je
maintiens en feutre bah oui c'est pas
son point fort mais bon il est numéro 3
mondial
s'est qualifié pour les candidats il a
été finaliste au championnat du monde
mais en fait c'est comme quand on vous
dit fait derrière sa vraie surface la
terre battue c'est vrai trouve c'est
vrai en fait il est plus faragher mais
il a quand même déjà gagné roland garros
et
et puis il avance il a fait plein de
finale
mais c'est pas faut quand même quoi au
juste
c'est pas parce que c'est lui qui va
donner des pièces à chaque coup non plus
par un soin conquois enfin c'est juste
ça mais bon tu as well as jamais
menaçants à les championnats du monde de
blitz c'est pas son truc pas sa cadence
est d'ailleurs d'avis dans les
déportations de 47 ans était pas du bus
était dure rapide mais autant dans les
douze parties us ici silva rien à envier
aux rapides c'est pas la même chose
donc voilà
après mais quand voire de classe tu peux
quand même aussi bien joué même si c'est
pas trop tard tu as cadence l'air en
prod châssis glitz il avait beaucoup
souffert il est très étonné
pas il était dans les derniers du
classement fabien je suis pas sur 32
joueurs ou 36 il était alors à la 22ème
vingt trois mois je n'ai que des
spécialistes du blitz mais tu vas y
réussit quand des joueurs comme çi kiev
tu vois des gars comme ça qui sont 26 50
26 25 en temps réel il avait du mal en
billets de cent
et après comme je le disais en
avant-match off ça c'est parce que c'est
pas
parce que c'est pas un buteur c'est que
je pense il voulait pas si demain la
cadence normale c'est du blitz il va
s'entraîner à fond et ça va devenir un
bon buteur mais délaisse un peu le truc
et il ya des jours ils encore bien des
jours il n'est pas en forme mais les
jours où il n'est pas en forme il va
vraiment être en dessous quoi là il est
dans un bon jour et du coup il défend sa
chance
je sais comment la maximus que
une fête français je pense à mes propres
enseignante en français 1 qui agissent
invité un peu tout faire pour preuve
cette il ya des problèmes' à détourer
fin et tu le bloc en fait ils pu
reprendre le tour
attention à un moment donné il peut
essayer de te claquer c'est un truc
genre tout reprend aussi sans fin j'ai
un
chat a bouffé dh
mais
il re défend bien en fait c'est moins
grave maintenant que ça a été mais mal
autant bah ça c'était prévu dans le plan
mais peut-être tour à quatre où tour à 3
pour tomber trois tombes et quatre tours
ce qui est à toi ouais le taquine son
côté quoi je sens qu anne
fabiano
donc en can c'est à dire enfants morgane
un
peu le nom ses voisins c'est
oui mais ça je vais tranquille mais là
c'est plus rugbystique ou pauvre et le
sud ouest
pourquoi pas bah pourquoi pas du tout
je vois qu'il ya un truc marrant et
proches 5 pouces et six tours prenait
fin de faux premier vite attaqué fin 3 4
j'allais
moi j'étoufferai que j'évite serrant le
cou qui fait quand je sais plus quoi
jouer
ouais bon ça se passe tout va la
position négative
je paye pour un
homme de dieu des trucs je dirais c'est
pas assez
mais mon kg 5 qui se replacent rebelles
louis peu
sapeurs
qui je suis très fier huit salles
il a neigé 6 mais bon il a quand même et
il a bloqué la case l'a bloqué ici s'est
il s'est replacé à etterbeek et 8 mai à
sa clique vite on va pas trop sur celle
là c'est ça va trop vite pour nous
mais il est en cannes fabi pascal et du
rein
lui tous les bons coups mais il est
impressionnant c'est impressionnant les
amis
parce qu'il va tenir malgré tout c'est
dur ma position je sais pas comment tu
tiens ça mais tu pousses il est chaud
fabiano ce soir weepu sans faille rien à
[ __ ]
tout ce qu ils envoient coiffage
envoie un autre garde j'aurai un
deuxième mais là je crois que ça se
passe bien pour maxi maintenant mais bon
ça a été ça gagne sur le clic au hasard
pendant ces 3 ml les blocs à de bien
jouer et maxime
barrages c'est sûr jamais parti aux 7
mais bon c'est peu ouais bonne pièce
attention quand même il va repartir en
g8 qui est aussi ce qui est des saints
qui couvrent il empêche tour c'est cette
fable
qui est le 3 qui est pro f 5 et mais il
se démène en fait je pense qu'il peut
prendre est il prend tout ce qui peut
laisser sacrifier la boîte est changée
la fois il a pas encore peur enfin oui
c'est ça aussi la joie et d'espoir que
attente est invaincu en six ans et ça
y apparaît n'ya pas y'a pas de ya pas de
pattes sais rien il ya trop de pièces
pour fabi
il est en cannes quand même fabiano ce
soir il va être dangereux fab
il se bat on pousse que jusqu'aux
aisselles hyper chiant il tomba il tombe
plutôt les poteaux ou presque bon c'est
vrai là il tombe mais c'était pas loin
je crois que c'est la pause
ah oui oui c'est la petite pause
sur un peu à une belle passe d'armes
maxime qui revient à un point
allez faut s'accrocher côté français
fabiano est dans un grand jour il va
falloir aller le chercher il faut le
déboulonner de speechless petite [ __ ]
pas beau mais le pub si par ses
magnifiques
gabon on est heureux
trois minutes de pub
wen enfin bien non il en rit sénat et
l'envoyer à eux ils envoyaient bailly
les perdez mais il envoyait des gens
voient à l'abattoir c'est un vrai encore
un autre
enfin ben
j'ai pas compris maxime a gagné la
dernière le score et 7 6
il a appris le clic au hasard fabienne
ça qui clique et à cliquer et recliquer
de partout quoi tu es un bon hazard mais
bon c'est à dire c'est vraiment bien
cliqué comme ça vient des fois il a fait
de son mieux
sa clique
rendez compte
ça va reprendre après meiway match très
plaisant à suivre c'est cool
ouais c'est cool
c'est cool c'est cool à part un petit
message pour là
pour répondre
ce mouvement
pour le tournant avec la société
générale pour les
pour les étudiants c'est quand alors
déjà le 12 le 9/9 en retard sachant que
ma vie je sais que c'est le fait c'est
très bon
en fait comme je suis sensé commenter
donc le neuf et que je parle avec les
américains et mes crises
12 slash 9 quand ils mettent le moins en
premier on fait du coup quand tu vois ça
tu penses 12 septembre enfin
je suis con et
je sais que c'était le 9 décembre et
quand je ne tueront kadrige est bien la
bonne date et du coup comme j'ai ce truc
dans ma tête en images mentales en
voulant par les usagers sur ce 12 qui
vient
9 voilà ok le soir du match de maxime et
sans même pendant le temps où ce juste
une heure actuelle match maxime sera
décalée du coup l'exploit est
très important pour la société générale
serait important le match
c'est pas
le soir mais je sais pas quelle heure
exactement
non mais je suis pas tout seul je suis
je suis sur plein de trucs mais c'est un
bouton je suis très heureux de ce toit
des étudiants c'est sympa d'avoir un
tour à des chèques je trouve que c'est
bien
beau et ses étudiants de tous partout
quoi faire oui mais oui à dire
supérieurs française de prendre les
cannes et il ya des belles têtes
d'affiché en faire assez bas
mais oui
ça clique sur des choses comme
ça clique
ça faisait donc ils s'alimentent non
sans rendre hommage c'est un beau match
ce soir fab
ya picot scop qui jouais pas je crois
comme détroit qui va partir
grand favori du tournoi
je réponds stream si on a pas on n'a pas
d'eau avec nom de vrai mais bon faut la
grèce plus grande plus plus très
longtemps et à ce qu il reste une heure
si tu veux boire n'hésite pas non
ce qu'on est fatigué tout ces castes
n'ont pas spécialement après je veux
dire ce que je dis souvent les choses
comme elles sont c'est difficile quand
tu commandes de skype pour un speech est
un très honnêtement là le match est
sympa donc on kiffe mais de base voilà
quand on se parle ce matin qu en garde
l'emploi du temps des trucs à casser tu
vas tu as nostra badiou ce match là je
vais écouter l'oracle le match speech s
est tu as ces packs cocher dans son
calendrier comme leeuwen que tu rêves de
regarder mais en fait ils ont forcément
il se trouve que là c'est un beau match
mais en soi
surtout temps à ce moment de l'année en
fait il ya eu plein de moments de
l'année où j'ai espéré qu'il ait lieu
jeanjean les gens ils sont par l'apec
magie tient là il ya un creux de deux
trois mois c'est dommage qu'ils aient
pas le speech esman en
début d'année par exemple il ya eu des
moments un peu de creux et tu disais
tiens un speech est ce serait cool en
fait mais c'est vrai que là tu viens
d'enchaîner grands suisses
championnats d'europe par équipes
match de championnat du monde est là au
milieu de ça un moment donné qu allait
dans les jours de repos au surplus
aliments de ta d'état du speech est
enfin c'est comme si bien dedans
enchaîner vraiment au tennis grand
chelem atp ni le master's
entraîné un futur qua non mais vraiment
oui bon bien peur mais là tu vois et
donc du doigt après là le match est cool
donc c'est vraiment sympa c'est un beau
match mais mais c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué hein
après aval car assez solide
je sais pas comment vous expliquer en
fait mais je suis sous x à fait solide
soit tu peux avoir kasparov et karpov
il se trouve que oui c'est génial mais
passent pas maintenant
mais là le match est serré il est sympa
il ya des belles parties puis je pensais
que fabiano serait vraiment marcher
dessus honnêtement ce qui n'est pas le
cas il nous offrait un beau combat et
maxime donc il est reparti sur la
française toi faut prendre force
beaucoup plus que tout à l'heure il va
me faire parce que oui mais bon là tard
ok déjà et thaler taille par ok et
s'était tu te fais de voir partout mais
là c'est fixer les loin tu vas te faire
un relationnel dame est à moins de faire
racheter un tour j'ai 4 ans t'as plus
d'autres plans et encore le mental l'a
perdue celle d'avant vous référons à
châteaulin comme ça il fait de mon truc
mais malgré tout
genre après on prie on passe un bon pour
faire j'ai quatre on s'en fout même si
la grande baignoire
soit g4 banon soit de fiqh et bien
qu'ils aient le vent je sais pas quoi
mais tu joues pour ce à quoi
à qui a été un cavalier à dieu j'ai
quatre
seraient vos de revoir magnus a lancé ce
pitch est ce moi j'aimerais bien le voir
à la va vite c'est l'impressionnant bas
l'année dernière la demi-finale contre
maxime était vraiment magnifique un
boxeur ghanéen ouais ouais c'est un très
beau match mais tu vois c'est très bien
placée dans le calendrier l'an dernier
c'est que c'est
la programmation est vraiment importante
des quatre c'est bizarre non pourquoi
pas b3ppo
aussi entre potes oui je sais pas un
mais quatre noms mais on va voir ce que
ça fait de l'avancé et noir mais le roi
c'est les blancs qu il faut
en fait je pense b4 suivra en plus pour
bloquer
il revient là ne veut pas avoir à 5 mais
surtout d'énormes visite plan que j'ai
cinq jours c'est une position assez
marrant parce que les deux les deux
elles sont fermées et ont un potentiel
d'ouverture à 85 m dames et g4 ou g5 le
droit
mais si on a retranché cinq c'est juste
très mal actuel en fait parce que tu es
mort à la lhdaa mais tu fait rouler
dessus et le droit est tellement partout
quoi
je pense maxime est vraiment bien donc
il faut lui tirer mais sont fous
vers 1 h 5 peut-être il échangera s'il a
besoin
fabien c'est marrant quand même qu'il
ait raté le f pour sauver un la case
il devait faire
j'étais triste g5 qui vont voir
un mois ils devront fixer ce côté maxime
mais j'aime bien voir le g5 point
intéressant de cette position fab soit
et c'est possible qu'on beats étaient
des meilleurs réflexes que dans ce type
de position parce que ça que toi tu
joues beaucoup de françaises et c'est
peuvent comme comme maxime n'est pas
forcément un joueur naturel de française
naturel oui non après mon lit j'ai cinq
ans stoke quand même c'est à dire que la
ressource ne pas disposer de la position
attention parfois de pas se prendre
ban a des trucs sur cases blanches qui
peuvent tomber c'est en fait si tu
pouvais faire qui les prend des cinq qui
on prend en fou prend sans perdre le
fouet à voir les douches punto chez
avancé tu le ferais un
si tu peux échanger calais compte ses
deux pions tu le fais
on peut tu as juste un coup de dames qui
indique yves 7 g 5 du promu qui a mené
toute votre cadre
c'est ce qui pousse qu'il veut s'il
tente de faire mais fallut en fait tu
veux jouer avec à 4 maintenant et de la
bécasse blanche qui est 17e que tu
kiffes 7
c'est marrant parce que c'est les blancs
qui joua les leroy et noir qui joue à
l'ale dame maintenant c'est les noirs
qui joua les droits les biens que joël
dame ça
ouais bah écoutes je sais pas encore si
cependant cet art et chiots ce que c'est
très fermé et très dur ça peut jouer au
chat et à la souris longtemps qu
est ce que tu peux tenter avec les
blancs un genre de dames un cavalier 2
kg un fonds veut le fouquet strong
enough 4 bon peut-être viennent pas de
retour à chute mais peut-être que non
mais tu peux vraiment me devrait
intégrer fer qui va faire ces trois
bateaux reprend 1,4 g prendre quatre y
verra mais la dame oms et 2 à 2 parabole
et le cavalier pas censé être plus forts
et actuel en bessin dicton oui que les
fous à il veut peut-être dame un fou des
infos à 4
ans c'est toujours compliqué je sais pas
très complexe
position en blitz que l'ong
marrant en dames heures et départ pour
ce plan h 4
et pour foot et un recycler le fouet à
25 des cinq qui a valu à cette food rsa
c'était à peu près ma variante
qu'il faut quatre beaux fous
ou peut-être pas perdre à b5
du coup d'amd vitupère page 4
disons
bienvenue et bien max os que caissier
bicis
ils valent manoeuvrait
fabi dans la sauce septembre famille
c'est pas ma position peut-être qu'il va
claquer la cale non ce que je pense
parce que bon les cases noires c'est
toujours quand même des cta plutôt fou
de caisse dans la khl et noir
lady gaga je pars quand il écrivit si je
perds pas b5 pour l'instant
je voudrais que ça serait peut-être le
fouquet de rêve
mais je crois qu'il verrait en ré agencé
et maxime va taper b5 en force
ça devrait gagner là pour maxime
je pense
ouais
il
va la claque et la cale max pour le loge
puntos mais ça sert bien côté
séville était soumis d'amd
[Musique]
238 km cette soirée
il a call il la claque la cale mais bon
c'est trois il reprend 1,4 il veut
attaquer c'est chaud mais les familles
en fait si c'est marrant parce qu'il est
lent mais il a un beau cliquer au hasard
par contre là c'est dur de cliquer un
5ème étape à d cheikh en c1
trois cette attention ouais
si ce passé six mois du clic aux hommes
là ça va cliquer il veut tout river to b
bon certes et à ses saillies comique et
noir ouais ouais il ya deux trois échecs
mais attends ta mme bérubé dame cet os
6 passes et 8 fois en six matchs ratés
il a raté un virage et maintenant
non
il a raté m'attendant fabiano assez
incroyable
il a raté m'attend note
max max va la gagner c'est le tournant
du match bah oui mais attendent un raté
de matane a raté way
ou
le matin un raté incroyable un plus
besoin il veut toujours faire perpètrent
il fait pas surtout qu'ils pouvaient
revenir avec dams est indécis c'est le
reprendre un
proche à change tout ça ça fait 8 6 a
fait 7 7
ah oui nos ratés matin ça fait mal un
bas surtout de la perdre par nature
beaucoup plus tard on te dis que j'ai
raté mes temps n'est pas grave mais
mais
bah ses fans et leur différentiel de
place de +20
magnifique
mais ce contre incroyable de fabiano bah
ouais
il a raté ma tendre c'est quand même
rarissime à ce niveau même avec peu de
temps un
prêt c'est pas le match le plus fréquent
c'est un match de ben laden oui
mais c'est pas le brigand oui mais bon
gagner aux échecs non mais oui tu
attends exactions et un exemplaire de
gagner aux échecs tu la gagnes quoi des
dégâts c'est un petit exemple la famille
quoi
ouais
marrant même ses parties rapides mais on
l'avait dit un maxime normalement doit
être au dessus dans le petit jeu en fait
il un bon kick au hasard mais enfin
c'est vraiment l'intuition qui place les
pièces tactiquement il est beaucoup
beaucoup moins fort que maxime pouvoir
va petit à petit mais ça c'est sûr que
ça
maxime il est très fort pour ça
maxime est très fort mais cette fois on
laisse trois deux un cheikh
jarrah une vente où je crois que ça va
pas s'y fait et b3 tu te fais changé
qu'il prend 4
immédiatement il t'as pas envie de voir
ça et de le calculer chaque coup et ai
dit ok c'est fait c'est fait
en tout cas maxime
est revenu est revenu à flot il vient de
gagner trois parties consécutivement
sauvé des eaux dans la dernière ah ouais
bon après les mérites et quant
à lui mérité mais bon il est en cours
n'ont pas forcément un tournant c'est
forcément un tournant positif ya eu un
tournant négatif un peu plus tôt dans le
match là c'est le tournant très positif
j'estime qu'au parti jeune chef est
dommage cette
partie pour
sa clique un
fait rayonner ya quand même une très
bonne intuition c'est étonnant pour un
joueur qui a été numéro 2 mondial
pendant tant d'années
équipe toujours objectivement
ouais c'est vrai que
ça reste un gros morceau famille
du coup dur à juger ce position chacun a
ses problèmes alors les normes trop est
fiable et toi bien placé mais montre
qu'un petit pion doublé il ya cinq qui
fait n'importe quoi il n'avait pas le
choix car c'est là parce qu'il doit être
là mais fitia pas accès à cette case a
baissé sa non tu peux imaginer qu'il ait
cette pièce est cuite un jour mais c'est
très long et puis donc je sais pas
mais tous ces problèmes dur
dur à dire
or on ne dit rien du coup
ça va partir comme tout à l'heure je
préfère me mets tu vas faire genre d
icade b6 et te dire qu'après tu as tout
le temps du monde pour organiser avec
les noirs si la turquie et baies 3 5
je vais faire pousser ça te laisser
bouffer à l'étouffé pas vu sa note
abaissée en fait tu dois les pions et tu
tiens mais maxime qu'il faut en g3 corps
là maintenant je préfère que benoît même
je sais pas si ça va passer même un
tatouage cet accès gratuit sur la barre
et qu'on appelle crible
mais d'un autre côté on est hyper solide
ya qu une faiblesse ça doit tenir en
vrai bon il veut il veut aussi d'un truc
à elle nommée fait il va pas toucher ses
pions il va attendre à 5 y aura touché 6
assists b6 et b 6 à 6
ça c'est connu quand adoption à plat tu
peux tu ne touches pas tu me touches pas
et adapte stratégie d'antijeu
[Musique]
et maintenant il veut car elle est la
fille kg 6 pi voir
il faudra peut-être d'un match 8 tours
h67 hamas est bon il va tricoter quoi
mais bon maxime barabé droit de l'autre
côté c'est nul ça doit être quand même
je pense
pas non c'est vraiment le la règle des
deux faiblesses
une faiblesse ne doit pas surpris la
partie la maxime en a qu'une
elle a partout ramener blindés et tenir
je vais faire comme le blitz que les
féodaux jour
toutes les pièces j'ai fait les pièces
au soir je ne savais pas de co prend
pour sa chanson en
échange une part de ge à mes tâches trop
faible
habitué à deux blindés c'est un seul sa
seule faiblesse et donnent l'exemple
bref trois cavaliers tu vas tu as pays
si
on va rester très bien vu de la part de
maxime non mais chut sylla il a pris le
temps de réfléchir
et de l'appliquer au hasard
non pas du tout même non ça a l'air
d'aller là ça tient bien le 2e tour un
autre je pense exactement la même chose
que toi
ça va très bien pour le moment
tarifs 6 / insiste abc sur les 6 à 6 à
peyrecave à un moment donné ne pas avoir
un truc un peu con genre adam des huit
qui gagne un tempo tu vois on évoque un
ventre et un en f1 je peux vous bref
trois points sur
63 et aux rêves trop ce que plus prises
en d2 dans votre ol 2
7 km landes et la
surproduction il faut des huit jours
ouais
il a peut-être poussé cette pour la même
chose intéressante cette partie encore
basse et même si le solde avant
en plus simple pour faire de cette fois
mais très faim devant issue
lcc bouillant les amis on a tous peur et
tout peut arriver là
là ces choses ont plus de temps pour le
toit on ferme et on s'attend à donner
quelques va devoir faire tarifs 4 blanc
il fait tout
ça ça devrait aller pour maxime
josse voir s'il perd encore
seydou keita ifri de calais
mais maxime les prend pas
non il va s'en vouloir fabiano l'a été
en contrôle bah il était mieux il va
mettre les tours emprise de partout et
ouais
bon
les spécialisations ce que je pensais
qu'il allait faire rentrer bien drôle et
coloré s'est très très bien joué
il va pouvoir pylônes et maxime
mais il est vraiment il est vraiment
plus fort qu'il ya peu de temps à la
pendule
il est vraiment beau nettement plus fort
comment vous pouvez dire ça
on le dit quoi on y
voit les regarde comme c'est bien joué
ils ouvrent tout est là mais
c'est magnifique
c'est matin ouais ça fait deux parties
là ça fait mal à la tête pour fabiano
ils auraient pu avoir quatre points
d'avance
parfois en avance par dont il se
retrouve avec un point de retard et
maxime qui envoie la nada surf est oui
alors est-ce que tu sortes après pas en
quoi c'est la question
un pompier empoisonné
ou bien non votre pion quatre victoires
consécutives pour maxime
plus adroits dans le petit jeu fab
faya non en fait ça il a une bonne
intuition
quelle belle voix tempo ils n'y arrivent
pas ils n'y arrivent pas fabi
en dessous légèrement en dessous
à lutik ithaca pour pour maxime et plus
plus plus fort dans le petit jeu hein on
connaît les points forts et les points
faibles des des deux hommes normalement
les cadences longue favorise plutôt
fabiano qui est le meilleur joueur et
les cadences rapides et blitz qui
favorise plutôt maxime
mais on voit que l'écart est ténue entre
entre les deux
mais là j'ai du mal à voir fabiano
revenir dans le match menant
bons ballons tu viennes penser à
l'argent les concessions pour le pire -
parce que si on doublait parce qu'ils
ont passé
ça va mais pas que dix ont été passés
tam attendent un tas machin tu as raté
ça tu allais pu l'être derrière fait tu
peux tu peux avoir un c'est surtout le
fait qu'il me le donne avant coup de
blues ouais
tu peur un gros coup de blues côté côté
fabi
après cette finale moi je trouve en
blitz et toujours changeante l'option
deux mois
d'avancé
a juste eu peur des gâteries quoi
doubler toi
4,4 à détroit
je suis tordu
8c 6g carey tu commences à être lu avec
fougue ne fait pas plaisir et je pense
mais c'est un beau match un pour le
moment ça a accroché la maxime qui vient
vraiment de
reprendre le dessus
mais attention
attention de pas ne pas laisser les
points au filet ya pas du tout
sort dé 6,3 g 7 à 6 france et 6 ou là le
roi va se retrouver mal à un peu
moi j'ai cette affiche 6 non juste à
temps je souhaite obliger à saint-orens
et 6,5 c'est perdurer tout reprend ses 6
il faut prendre soin de toi donc je
souhaite obliger f6 croyait fuite france
et 6 en français si ce processus a
déclaré m ça pue
pas mal d'échecs très bien joué vous
vous la tour s'être 3 et on se retrouve
dans ma naissance c'est très bien joué
ils ont ça c'est au tour des six faits
mais c'est mal joué oui
c'est facile mais
aussi un il n'est pas bien fait un tu
voulais mettre au trèfle s'est très bien
défendue de la part de maxime à ce petit
coup déchets qui inattendu bien jouer
et là il va défendre
ma décision
je sais pas peut-être aussi c'est bien
mais des
champions et monte à l'avancé sans issue
de cette tour b 7e
droite et 8 passes a jamais fait
j'aurais même pas considéré je n'aurais
pas pensé non plus j'ai très bien joué
en fait
fait il veut bloquer le boeuf sais pas
quoi [ __ ] mais bien un jeu permanent
qu'est ce qu'ils sont forts j'aurais
même pas penser au coût leur ai dit je
conseillerais pas tu coûtes pas le roi
comme ça quoi mais en fait si
stratosphérique un
son incroyable quand même
le niveau
ça
le fab ce genre de coup
m le rend à 8 pour bloquer le pion je
n'aurais jamais pensé
c'est hyper bien joué en fait ça bloque
complètement en fait c'est la logique de
10 amis on va revenir vers le pion à lui
il a vraiment donné il sera pas à mi
chemin à quoi
tout cela messi ballon d'or mais vous
avez dit que c'était à mon sort et enfin
fait pas il ya aucun suspense en fait
je suis estomaqué une nouvelle fois par
le niveau de jeu fab
est nul
nul assez facile
même sans plonger cinq cellules faciles
un peu moins mais oui
j'avais demandé à maxime une fabrique
c'était facile
facile pour des thèmes
après ce temps long gain s'est jamais
pareil
tu sais que c'est facile je le donne
mais c'est peut-être il a fait au bon
moment j'ai l'impression
que du coup tu progresses pas
faire ce 6 mai c'est d'avancer un peu tu
avances pas en fait
à chacun mais
n'avance pas et qui est blanc
à
ouais je sais pas si comment il va y
avoir tout tenté quelque chose quand
même c'est pas trop comment qui
longtemps mais
ces quatre c'est un peu jeune pour
d'être autour des six jeux pour
ça change quoi par rapport à une fille
dort normal c'est que top 5 derrière les
cinq derrière
on est offert ses six
oui tu fais rien
c'est de refaire son truc mais en fait
ça n'a pas fonctionné
bah tu fais rien qu'il veut tour à j-7
genre tour 17 et la finale gagnerait
mais
déçu
oui maxi n'avait pas menti
ouais
attentats cette
ouais ouais georges pas des masses sera
cette histoire
j'ai
très bien joué de la part de maxime qui
bloque voilà il ya un tour b 6 échecs
qui est marrant
c'est six tours pensait 6 en fait ouais
bof si je pense à tour g5 et orphan tour
francis très bien aussi
et le path qui va se présenter
tissu retour ce dossier sans doute parce
que toujours échec sur l'habituel même
tomber cette
ba oui ça bah oui quand même
alors bien sûr ce truc et on iturbe ici
surprendre s'éprend v6 oui ça faisait
pas très beau et
très convaincant l'option et ans elle
faisait pareil
c'est au coude avant
tant pis si ça faisait pas tu
es roi ses cinq tours c6 tout repenser
cette fois que tout repenser sa tu avais
pas eu de proposition voiture faisait le
tour des six tours se servir si tu sais
que t'as rien à faire tu fais rien puis
lorraine entre les pattes
parce qu'il a fait c'était plus facile
ces derniers en 3 + 1 priori a priori
wind 45 secondes ok on ferait bien de
tourner à +16 fera pour maxime ouais
quand même à plus de 1 voie plus de très
larges puissant très bien et franchement
heroes heroes
sera bien aussi mais donc tout est bien
tout est magnifique
ouais ça redevient se passer là pour
maxime une nouvelle fois
on
va déjà vu ce genre de position
américaine en blessaient t'es bizarre il
veut à 5 et là tu apprends veux quand tu
veux donc c'est un peu différent
c'est la fin du temps
à 5 bizarre
bizarre parce que c'était maxime qui va
pas à votre corps va nous refaire un
rôle à 10 h soit que machin
qu'on a compris c'est c'est l'idée du
match ses positions
faby qui va envoyer
real bull est alors je vous colle avec
la la la la la séquence de bullet et un
peu on peu trop longue la trop
d'importance une demi heure c'est
vraiment l'ont finalement c'est le lacet
le canton ce qui va et qui a le plus
d'importance 9 10 15 minutes ce serait
bien juste pour pour finir way serait
sympa d'avoir une demi-heure bon ça
al'avantage de maxime dans ce match
parce que ça brille garros et la
contrée cas où c'est un petit peu un
petit nuage oui oui bon on ne voulait
plus que nous
maxime qui veut la jouer balle cavaliers
n'est pas un rêve c'est un nom qui va
être très heureux
ici ce qui est du tiff très important
même ses six tours d2 maxime qui va se
placer
annoncera planus il est quand même assez
bien
prédit ce qui allait se passer dans le
match la non le scraigne ce sujet on n'a
rien à faire en fait un
nom mais il avait prédit que l'espagnol
sait irait pas et prédit machin philippe
rey dit que ça allait très bien se
passer parce que dubaï fait dans
l'équipe ont fatigués pas donc bon très
bonne donc c'est pour ça que ça se passe
mal
et du coup pour dans l'équipe on ne sait
pas mais il sait qu'il n'y ait pas
les cartes c'est aussi une quarantaine
c'est aussi
peut-être qu'en fait les justes en
effectif de carl zeiss bien sûr et bien
sûr tu sais qu'ils viennent j'en suis
bien sûr mais ça ne va pas dans l'équipe
ça peut pas être vu comme une trahison
aussi
bon soit un jour je ne serai pas à son
premier fait d'armes du bois
ok
c'est beaucoup et un mec qui m'a nui
dans un commentaire hazard wing kevin
dit toujours vraiment du mal de double
offre disons qu'il n'est pas top mondial
et les pattos bande annonce mais c'est
grave c'est il va dire que c'est un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde
il ne fait vraiment exprès parce qu'ils
n'apportent j'aime bien
je connais un peu il est très sympa mais
20 juste
attirer en fait ils soient fonda fait en
fait quoi il n'est pas forcément où tu
places la limite du top mais
vu qu'on va dire c'était genre au moins
deux mille sept cent cinquante
bas
du dos et ça parle
ça se passe pas bien là pour fabien ça
devrait faire plus de pour maxime la cei
clapson zougeïev cette secte a dit mme
rice plus faible attaque touche à touche
touche quoi c'est ça avait de tous les
cadres importants tué touche pas marrant
en fait atteint un bon niveau un peu du
niveau 2 des travaux va se taper sur la
gueule quoi à la bombe niveau 1 on a
perdu toute une game admise au sein on
ne réussissait pas tenir devant
bof j'ai 3 mb si les regarde le kg 4
celle inverse en fait mais c'est moi qui
te piquer les cartes en fait pour ça
qu'ils ne trouvent pas ton bref cette
klm prend un système prendrait cinq
syriens du coup à 5 complètement
justifiée
bon ça se passe bien ce match parce que
tourner à plus de avons en plus la
cadence qu'il nous faudrait que ça va
être ça va être tranquille je suis
inquiète et allemand obtient même quand
fabien et à +3
je ne m'inquiétais absolument pas
un mais quand ces matches ils sont
tellement longs quand tu sais qu'un
joueur est vraiment au dessus de l'autre
les surprises sont très rares dans ce
format
mais même si tu es mené au score même si
ça se passe pas très bien
on essaie de bien sûr j'avais eu la
seule chose j'avais peur c'était la
connexion action
on dénombre 2 clics ses pions favy
encore ses beautés qui peut qu'il sait
plus on les envoyait puntos c'est ça et
bons latins sont un peu plus avancée que
les autres
ok donc ça tourne
ça tourne à plus 2 pour mac si on va
mettre une petite page de pub et on se
retrouve on se retrouve pour la suite
dans six minutes à peu près
ouais mais qui se présente à moi oui
mais tranquille mais là c'est
et en plus je crois qu'en demi-finale
ils jouent pas un génie
non c'est pas votre nom je sais plus qui
joue
à scandale et je veux dire mais c'est
pas si facile ça veut dire vraiment un
côté
des rapports tsarine fait pas trop peur
quoi
mais tu sais qu'ils jouent mais bah je
sais pas je dis au hasard non mais je
crois que c'est pas un génie au prochain
tour
comment on fait pour savoir
attends attends c'était quelque part en
plus on l'avait tout à l'heure devant
les yeux
oui non ces juniors
à temps en temps un je crois que c'est
pas un génie s'assurer qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de génie en fait dans le temps
ah non mais un ses sauts
c'est pas facile
en fait après le xo n'était pas en forme
en ce moment et qui veut n'importe quoi
a beau le savoir mais
et l'autre à temps c'est quoi il va
découvrir un à rognan ding favori
comme aux collections chinoise n'a qu'à
guibon
amsa match se rapportent ni à la wii là
tu te retrouves ex en dominos et ouais
c'est ça en fait je savais qu'il y avait
un truc facile dans le tableau mais je
sais plus quoi ce que rapportent en fait
ils s'étaient connectés dernières
secondes il trouvait plus son mot de
passe il en a absolument rien à faire
donc il sera facile d'air france et
niall sarine qui va se qualifier de bon
augure avant ouais il s'en fout
complètement faite rapporte
enfin thierry là il a sué contre sarah
n'a
en vertu du coup site hani al en demies
en fait vraiment aller en finale et
surtout on retrouve le hb et tu
retrouves le hachoir ça pourrait être
sympa
mais avec un fait maxime si basso la
demie normalement c'est
de pocket je suis ou moins enfin une de
pocket non mais quand même
pas si c'est à porte qui se met dans les
rapports c'est vraiment rien à faire en
fait sarine jeune maxime pertes
concernent ansari pizza et non c'est
impossible à moins qu'il ait une
connexion dégueulasse
c'est possible
et pareil c'est wesley
oui non non non il peut pas c'est la
partie de tableau un peu faible mais
c'est parce que firent où j'aï la fin il
était prévu pour jouer ouais bah oui
c'est pas pareil je veux poursuivre tant
que chirurgien on n'était pas mon temps
mais je pense qu'il a vraiment arrêter
le pitre sur internet ouais mais il a
bien fait
et du coup un
saut en quarts c'est chaud ouais
ouais mais je sens moins sur les toits
internet dernièrement après je sais pas
il n'a pas très bien joué le premier
match
bon allez faut déjà battre fabiano fab
jugé meilleur que maxime en bis 24 plus
en ce moment mais intrinsèquement
maintenant il faillit fait peur partout
en fait firoud
firoud fait peur par tous
pour cofiroute et vita on sait pas s'il
arrêtait volvo - même je voulais tournoi
arrive il fait plus à rien un clic j'ai
fait plus rien il se concentre sur sur
le vrai travail aux échecs
baltique non mais je veux dire aux
échecs
c'est ça quand tu fais tu t'entraînes
des heures et des heures chaque jour ce
travail d ouverture tu fais du calcul
t'arrête pas quoi les blitz basiquement
sur internet ça pas grand chose quoi
multi respecté le signal mais c'est pas
ne pas respecter dire que tu es moins
fort que maxime lacroix
sarine et champion du monde de blitz et
que fille rousse et meilleur joueur du
monde actuel et là vous êtes content
peut il être de trois réserves à ce ce
jugement radicale quand même
et du coup on en reparlera après demi si
vous voulez
après il peut très bien créer la
surprise ainsi créé la surprise vient
quand même été plus heureux que ce que
je pense à mes excuses
tu penses que maxime va s'imposer
aisément à partir de maintenant avec la
face bullet où il semble
être le le plus fort des deux bombes ont
une bonne chance je pense qu'on va même
pas assuré que ça va être un one way
ticket bah
ouais
répond juste famille à quel point vous
cliquez vite en
un clic et ça y va cliquer un nom mais
satisfait à cliquer études à cinq
secondes à la pendule ça ira pas pour
lui sykora cliquez dès la première
seconde
j'y crois pas du tout âge y croit pas
trop
à mon avis ça va être le massacre
la maxima da
on a eu à lui faire très très très mal
mon fab il veut son petit truc la
famille
issue
issus de ouf bright tranquille
tranquille et
tranquilliser à vos livres
en et il s'en fout complètement
honnêtement je pense qu'ils s'en fout
complètement vous avez pensé trucs
dedans
je le respecte quand ils disent tu as
des mecs en garde à vue fin
tu sais pas trop qui est le coupable ou
pas il dit bah c'est le mec qui d'art
c'est que c'est fait c'est fait jose
l'issue il s'affirme innocent et ils
sont là ils trouvent pas le sommeil et
la bonté la famille donne à fond des
mecs qui dort oui ça quoique bon il
faisant foi monde latin oui et candidat
dans six mois et je crois qu'il faut
weick tu vois c'est un joueur qui reste
je crois tu pas sur vos tour aso veuille
y commente le championnat du monde fin
fou mais vous savez moi ici
pas plus mal de se faire éliminer tu
vois
mais alors ça va mais il est sympa faby
des
noms mais maxime en plus ses coups
puisque après six balles wesley
et laura sa grosse de vie contres
dangereux et souvent il va peut-être
faire l'exploit et je veux contre ikea
ou après en finale c'est ça
bon ils attendent que ça reprenne ses
doivent attendre la fin de la page
publicitaire j'imagine
elle est sympa
la page publicitaire qui est parti
je sais pas plus gros oui ouais c'est
pas un truc c'est plus gros au sport en
fait c'est pas pour ça s'est passé
je sais pas pourquoi mais c'est pas
ok on a déjà plus ou moins vu cette
position tout à l'heure
dans une des parties je fus laquelle
on savait clic est un peu plus que
d'habitude ça va être un peu différent
des commentaires voilà ça envoie fab
maxime qui cliquent vide on sait pas
trop ce qui se passe en fait un clic ce
qui s'applique aux sans voix des coûts
un bon il se développe quoi ça va aller
comme ça défend et les tours mieux bas
est une tour en huit un quart et les ans
et 4
pop up un papa voilà sa part
donc il ya deux points d'écart maxime
qui
qui doit j'ai envie de dire assurée mais
on peut pas vraiment assuré dans une
lettre
les punto et
mais il va y avoir à peu près huit
partis dans cette cadence il faut que
maxime du coup perdre au pire 5,3 pour
pour avoir le 3 au départage et georges
commence des portages alors c'est de
nouveau une partie dans ces quatre
partis en bullet man
non mais ça ça ça ils le gardent depuis
un moment ça est vraiment l'accent sur
le sur le recul est à voir magnifique 1
à la maxime qui enchaîne les coups
quand ils gagnent le pion il est bien là
max il est libre
attention comme le key qui va venir
peut-être choper le fou à un pénible
fois f4 peut-être comme ça c'est
ça ouais non ça va en fait
votre sphère de b1 peut-être rien fait
tourner
on çà fait pions plus
perdre aux choux mais
ça a pas l'air
valère de faire mal je créerai plus de
dames bien sonné changé d'âme torrent
bien qu'ils nous embêtent à meubler
cette avec l'autre
dame c2 avant plus sinon ça y fait
maxime ça c'est important est d'avoir
seconde avance bien plus en plus
beaucoup de bons arguments
ouais ça a l'air d'être parfait le cas
et qui part en âge 5
fu de 15 voire qui va pouvoir revenir
vers des quatre peut-être
d'amd ou non il faut des 4 et d'objets
au vote et dames germa tessa affaire le
pount om et fabien quelques de 1871 à
ambühl est la différence de niveau est
quand même assez assez flagrante faire
de mieux et ça se ressent
abonnez-vous
ça joue sajou la petite catalan il reste
quoi il reste 27 minutes de jeu
maxime qui fait enfler le score
dans un match qui aura qui feinte qui
pour le moment ne paraît pas à pas du
tout dangereux pour maxime bon soit il
est bien bas public trois montées drôle
mais mieux
il est complètement en contrôle max
ça changez farming simulator ouais c'est
ça
le hockey et qui part en f4 en d3 qui va
aller visiter trois pour pour sécuriser
il n'y a pas de bessens qui aura le pion
c6 en l'air
dès que le client des cinq clubs maxime
qui va aller qui va les taper le pion
mais il va y avoir d'yeux 4-1 fab est
même en hausse de 1,4 g 5
je sens que je garde supporter ce
trotteur
retour à deux tours de regarde moi cet
orfèvre
et là ça va envoyer aux 4 et 6 est
faible ouais c'est 5 1 jour maxime tu va
peut-être prendre quatre points d'avancé
ici fab voilà ce serait il ya déjà un
break 1 2 point c'est le premier break
là c'est tout le break ça gagne 1,7
sorges way
et surtout maxime
qui est simplement le joueur le plus
fort dans ses cadences
à ce rythme de jeu fabiano
ne peut pas lutter face à la vitesse de
calcul du joueur français
très très tranquille
j'ai envie de dire il a toujours été en
contrôle 1 dans ce match même quand il a
été mené voyez une [ __ ] faire quand il
enchaîné trois défaites d'affilée mais
c'est tout est bon et c'est tout
on est quand même maman fallait arrêter
l'hémorragie et la faire rester rester
serein après il ya peut-être le dernier
tournant du match pour le moment en tout
cas c'était ce matin d'un rap et par par
fabiano qui a émis les dernier clou dans
son cercueil on met d'attention c'est
plutôt soldats c'est vrai que pendant
qu'on chante fab est ce qu'en fait il
m'a source et 8 à seyssins problème il
est changé d'âme prend 1,6 à la fin
ah oui non ça peut être pénible
la prise des six prix c'est un
attention maxime qui se refait une
petite frayeur face à tulle et une très
belle position là bon inky témoins et
tour ces trois noms et de 9,8
raté par fabiano
retenir tout c'est vrai ça doit aller 20
ans pour maxime poudrier un clouage
supporters mais bon c'est juste rien et
puis avant fouet ouais
bon ça doit juste bien aimé
ça doit tenir mais bon de justesse
faut pas se faire prendre par derrière
en fait pas évident pour un homme bien
c'est le ceto qui voudraient m
il y arrive pas pour le mans fabiano à
mettre son 7ème qui veut tour f5
maintenant a raté par maxime
il encore qui a aidé deux peut-être non
abandon rouge tu vois on était allé trop
vite en besogne il revient à deux points
brest pour se rencontrer et confiant
mais bon
j'ai 6 - on vient à petit qu'ils aient
des quatre mois en masse qui met maxime
est pardon
fabien et qui a gagné 90 points en
bullet alors c'est parce qu'il faut
absolument jamais un fabiano ça ne
m'intéresse pas du tout je crois le
bullet
84e va partir après on voit que même si
ses joueurs ne jouent que jamais dans
cette cadence ils sont tellement forts
qui réussissent à très rapidement
s'adapter maxime qui envoyait prochain
sa clique qu'elle n'arrive pas trop à
gérer les ouvertures fabiano j'ai
l'impression
c'est complètement différent fait aller
les ouvertures en buvette
c'est un truc assez étrange tic ouais
mais c'est 6 tc jeu normal comme fabiano
en fait qu'ils arrivent pas
c'est une manière une manière spécifique
de jouer pour voir en photo une activité
assez bizarre des fois tu as un fond je
veuille vendre que tu connais bien et ça
marche pas du tout genre là je pense
qu'il a bien joué et fabien cottereau du
bullet mais bon sang qu'est à 4 fait
fait un peu grise mine
il faut 17 ces quatre ans
bien joué et rejoué maxime
très très bien joué
il envoie les punto avance avance ouais
ça avance vite 1,6 à 52 secondes il a
cliqué tout tempo un
gala
pourrait reprendre ces deux jeux
facilité bien joué depuis en france est
de 5 c'est lui ramène les pièces pour
défendre ces cinq attaques
h67 défend
la position est magnifique 1 mais
attention ne pas de pas se faire
retourner
à l'appui on ses seins qui tombent raté
sa part fabiano la pression était trop
dure pour pour les blancs pour 17 est
tranquille pour protéger le pion à sept
et on s'en va et on and on peut pas
faire tour ces trois agressions tour
ailleurs être ailleurs
c'est très très très très très
tranquille fab il n'y a aucun risque
votre
carrosse havre
ac
c'est avant l'accident voilà c'est là il
pilonne
camille tchad a fini soit en g2 tacle
appuyé défend et c'est à dire ces fonds
que le tour allez on reprend trois
points d'avance
à maxime qui est qui est tranquille où
maxime qui est tranquille où
il enchaîne les points il enchaîne les
victoires
car jean després max est un requin en
photo avec c'était un délire avec toi il
a vite compris ah
oui un comprend vite hikaru il est pas
mou de la feuille
il n'est pas mou de la feuille
non mais ça se passe de nouveau bien
portier normand voit sa clique
et bien la photo le requin il est prêt à
manger en plus tu vas y mon bien ses
dents de requin clément ric et 10 6 mois
je sens
on sait qu'ils feraient
voile et s'il pouvait repasser à +4 fab
très beau ça ferait plaisir ah bah ça
tranquillise +4 en fait ça seul le sort
du match
je fais le double break
après il reste encore des parties mais
ça et que j'ai du mal à voir fabien de
revenir
j'ai du mal à le voir revenir
après je le voyais moins fort que sans
bulatov a bien non
bon match à
tous tous nos respects pour spectacle
fourni non non il a il a bien joué il a
juste été un poids léger dans le petit
jeu tactique c'est c'est tout mais
contre maxime ça ne pardonne pas maxime
avait aussi mis à mal l'an dernier car
carlos n 1 dans ce petit jeu tactique
après la prestation contre carlsson
était quand même au dessus mais j'ai
envie de dire maximy s'adapte un peu
aussi comme tout le monde à un niveau de
l'adversaire quand il a fallu mettre un
coup d'accélérateur un coup de collier
il a mis un vieux su faire il a su le
faire ouais
ça ceci toujours pareil c'est un peu
comme dans tous les sports elle match
serré souvent tu as le joueur le plus
fort au moment décisif qui fait la
différence
après mon arrivée quand même moins bien
on a trois qui est faible
fabien je voyais pas du tout à ce niveau
là en bulles à temps
ce qui va leur coller de nouveau au
score comme quoi ce matt
helm attendant raté
il pourrait revenir est là le roi
montrent leur aux normes très vite des 5
6 4
photo maxime
comme des gorilles peu mais bon c'est
juste très perdante allez il faut
essayer de la tenir le plus longtemps
possible mais il a pas de coups de fouet
en fait
ouais les deux minutes maxime
bono est fait et le cavaly qu'il va
revenir vers détroit
la direction qu'ils veulent
ou pas la pendule nom maxime est correct
il ay peu flag est ce un problème mais
il va pas jouer la pendule à faire
tourner le chrono puisqu'il est en place
que dans 18 mars et encore du temps
et ouais non mais tu vois
je voyais fabien se faire vraiment
marcher dessus en bullet
finalement qui explique ce qu'on voit
qu'il est vraiment pas du tout entraîné
un comme tu dis on voit là son
classement elo il est plus 90 - 90eme
absolument gmail en soi et pourtant
le joueur américain
bayer shering chaleur ça lui donne des
ailes alors je vous pose pour le ramener
à 8 un jour bien ça aussi je meurs un
homme qui a versé 500 cases
et donc faux mais ça ne sera pas le
temps de leur beau j'aime son endroit
envie de voir l'autre ans et 6 s'il
vient là pour le coup on mange
ta bouffe bouffe dame bouger tour huit
mois maxime et il a bien joué un set ces
risques où il a été tellement bon
j'ai 3
way à deux doigts de se prendre une
tactique
avec six à deux doigts ouais je sais pas
il ya trop de pièces jours sur 7 degrés
avec le foot et rock oui il y avait des
tours programme et java et c
est le roi g2 et bien joué de la part de
deux cas il veut dame détruites
je pensais que je préfère ça que d'avoir
17 ans
après c'est du bullet un
attention quand même
ouais il va faire ramener huit à vingt
huit ça va aller
de 2 à 4
ans maxime il est pas mal non vois tu
bouffes et il veut faire à des prêts à
mettre le fond des cinq bourses oui non
mais je la retire un peu dans les 6 es
tu tiens tout on n'en parle plus mais
est-ce que ce père maxime c'est mieux
hop bois pour peut-être surtout un
budget qui avait lui qui sautent partout
il est très bon 10 ans à
phu des cinq femmes progressistes
recuites d'envoi je suis trop de fautes
il faut des saints ok mais là ça peut te
re devenir moins dangereux
parce que lecavalier s'est focalisée bon
aussi son père poste finalement ouais
mais faut quand même faire gaffe ce
qu'il peut y avoir c'est 5 non ça va
comprendre de me rendre et
attention rage et 5
faire gaffe quand même trop j'ai fait ce
que j'avais à dire
on doit vous faire émerger cette on
attend h5
roi f53 ici ce 4 notre
sais pas si on dirait que ça va je vais
accorder de plus 3 42 richesse ne doit
pas aller mais je sais pas après un
essai hyper chaud et poussereau 17
pouces et 7 et de se cacher
sur 3 807 la faute de prêt lors du vin
je dirais mais pas sûr en fait
ce que tu vas aller en v8 quand même moi
ça non mais c'est pas faux du tout tu
veux un bébé je dis juste après leur
débauche mauvaise qualité j'ai déjà
gagné ou perdu comme ça sur les trucs
comme ça ça m'est déjà arrivé mais je
dépasse en fait il fait un truc de
courir nous avons eu huit d'abord et
peut-être des clous agendé à temps s'est
pas fait et fait encore
n'ont pas fait faux bond la suite
c'était bien la fête est dégoûté par des
pions écrit noir quoi 4h à 6h 7
maintenant ouais je sais pas si c'est
hyper fort tu fais ça tu es dame g8
ouais mais ravis d'annoncer
8 h 8
terrible mais bah écoute tout au plus un
mais
bien soit un parc à rona mais ça je me
suis déjà pris c'est très bizarre d'être
option est d'acheter plus actives à les
écoutes à ya pas de pause et six minutes
oya pas les 3000 6000 de pub o
ça n'est pas bien
là sans pub quand on fait quoi
non mais je pensais maxima effet les cas
étaient plus forts et que et que ça se
passait bien je ne voyais pas du tout de
retournement de situation mais le match
va être chaud jusqu'au bout il reste et
resterai minutes fab
y va fort que maxime serre le jeu en
fabiano cdu son travail crunch
il a dit s'entraîner avec renshaw
c'est là c'est peu dire la position
arrive près dans les françaises quand tu
perds le fou de cases blanches c'est dur
batta plus attaque
j'attaque mais
et la fougue et 5 x 3 ans les deux là
bas
mais quatre parmi les quatre fois droit
c'est un ça va ça tient pour maxime
ça tient peut-être juste damas cinq
voitures en tout point noir tu doublé
tour prendre et damas 5 et cavaliers h4
qui veut être
à la fois tenir les barbelés d'urban
rivals à tenir il va la tenir la femme
qui est des trois tours d un il va pas
plus loin le cavaly va devoir repartir
vers g6 probablement
centrale erik rinsch ça va détruire
ces s'entraîne peut-être à donner saba
aussi ils sont bien trop leur truc anti
canal pendant les commentaires que j'ai
vu ce soir le recalage à l'âtre auraient
ils craignent chou
il est trop belle
mais attention le world des meilleurs
streamer des meilleurs à machin j'espère
bien autour des nominés je suis nominé
aux profiteuse
tu as raison ce ne devrait pas l'être au
wef ou 4 kg 5 bien joué et maxime il a
spot rapidement qu'ils votent en fait je
sais pas
mais oui non français j'ai aucune chance
je t'annonce
mais il va pas être mieux la maxime qui
arrive en d6 option qui n'existe plus
j'avais des f-5 bien joué qu'à la part
de fabi
sécher sur réussi à défoncer enfin ces
faits en date des plus mal avec les
blancs je sais pas si tu vas gagner mais
non rien 5 oui nantais très bien avec et
blanc annoncé pions plus fab
amis ils envoient tout famille
recommence ouais mais a
pu revenir
ça contre on voit quoi wen ce magnifique
d'enfants le 17 juin anne on se place
bien j'aime bien son coup reda mais sans
hésitation je vais prendre bessette
peut-être tendue comme tous là bas mais
mais bon il fait froid c'est tour des 5
de taux devrait bien jouer
je pense qu un repas tiranges et cat way
to réussissent d'âme des uns mais bon
tu rejoins mes ouvrages de dames f3 et
la marge du parti
bon j'ai cette force et vite
ouais ok tour c'est un torse de f1
mais c'est n'importe quoi fab cher à
l'époux une dose de partout là il va
l'attraper
attend au merde y'a roigé six tours
prend 17
juillet les autres tout haut ce qui fait
gamin de huit heures
mais ici comme salis y aura un envoi de
deux bombes
c'est plus drôle de
voir les mecs c'est chaud de chaud c'est
fou de la partie d'avant sa tournée sais
pas comment les plus douces ont même y
avait un trou cette évaporation dès à
présent c'est en fait une fois en
rupture en descente et un super fort et
il me après le bébé par chico et de
le bce s quoi mais bon y'a pas du tout
sorti le rs
aller il va falloir il va falloir
s'accrocher on reste si on reste compris
je n'arrive pas à ne pas être confiant
en fait c'est je n'arrive pas à imaginer
en fait fabiano à bas la clé un maximum
vu lettre
[Musique]
j'ai passé tellement pas son truc
fabiano
s'est passé le pire format pour fabiano
en fait enfin tu peux pas faire pire et
c'est vrai c'est appâter ouverture ta
pâte à cadencement a foncé c'est une
catastrophe ou faite pour fabiano
devant après maxime tranquille en
vacances aussi à dubaï fin annoncée oui
c'est un match un peu spécial
mais quoi qu'il en soit je peux pas